get going I want to remind people that
wish to speak that I have a list of
people who have signed up in
advance and if you have not sign signed
up in advance you'll have to raise your
hand when I ask if there's anyone else
who wishes to
testy official script as chair of the
house DNA committee I find the DU to
state of emergency declared by the
governor as a results of the covid-19
pandemic and ordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12 first one executive order
20204 this public body is authorized to
be
electronic it is a public hearing on
bills referred to the committee and
scheduled the house
calendar an executive session may be
held on any Bill refer the committee
that has already had it here please not
there's no physical location for M of
the public to observe and listen
temporaneous to this meeting however in
accordance with emergency order I am
confirming that all members of the
committee and Select Staff have the
ability to communicate temporaneous
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform and the
public has access to contempor listen
and if invited participate in the
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone all
necessary information on access has been
made available in the house calendar and
through the electronic calendar on the
general cour website the notice for this
meeting complies with house rules and
RSA
91a anyone has who has a problem
accessing the meeting should call
271-3600 or email
HCS
leg. us if the public is unable to
access the meeting it will be adjourned
and
res all votes that are taken during this
meeting will be done by roll call vote
video
participation I'll start the meeting by
taking roll call attendance when each
member states their presence please
State whether there's anyone in this
room with you during this meeting which
is required under the right to
know and
representative would you please call the
thank you
chair representative algro
here representative
Bailey
representative present
alone representative
goalie I'll come back repres okay
representative
Judy
lanara I am here and
alone representative
leas
present representative
Maguire present representative
O'Brien we're supposed to be stating
where we are as well as that we're here
that's right representative O'Brien
could you please unmute yourself
you have to unmute
yourself
sorry there we go I'm present and
alone you are
physically we physically
where at home in your
office in the
legislature oh for me yes I'm in my uh
at home in my office okay thank you
representa representative
Pearson representative
Roy
here are you with the
L
yes representative
saso Excuse me yes we're
having we need to increase the volume on
many of these people for having hearing
them are you having an issue hearing me
you'll have to speak up folks
okay representative s sorry Santo
naso I'm here I'm alone I'm in the town
of hensdale okay representative
Schmidt I am present at my home office
and I am alone representative
Shu I'm present at my home in Pembrook
alone representative
Schultz uh representative schz you're
muted yes sorry um I am here in my home
and my husband will be in and out of
this room which is the
kitchen representative
yakubovich I'm here at home alone
representative scitech is arriving later
I'll check him in when he comes in I'll
call again representative
Bailey I am alone at home in
Milton representative
font I am home in Rochester and my wife
is in the
house thank you representative
goalie okay he was here earlier so I'll
just wait um until he arrives thank you
um roll
callete
mam
chair I'm I'm not going to be able to
hear what's going on testimony unless we
get the volume turned up partly it's
this thing but it's just the volume's
not enough at least for me okay thank
you um I I would also like to say that
um the representative that just spoke I
could hear him very well but um Madam
chair I hear you but it's it's um kind
of Echoes it's a little hard to
understand and it's not very
loud is that
better that's better yeah that's
better just to getos yes okay thank you
um Miss farling if you could ask h find
out how we turn up the volume here for
the
participants we we will need need that
because I was have a great deal of
trouble understanding the
members I I am texting um Scott Kelly
right
now okay thank you you're
welcome so our first bill
536 I have three people interested again
speaking
um representative
Shu you're you're
first Madam chair this is representative
G if we could please I'd like to um
admit um representative goalie to the
roll call he had to reboot his program
representative
goalie I am here home alone uh here in a
room alone and my wife is in another
room thank you I'm sorry for the
interruption that's fine while we're
interrupted uh who is not
here representative scch and
representative Pearson and
representative
Judy
okay yeah I'll keep an eye on them thank
you representative scitec will be here
physically sometime around 10 o'clock uh
representative Pearson will be will be
calling in I don't know about
representative Judy thank
you all right so representative Shu you
you have the
floor uh thank you madam chair I I would
um note however that the prime
sponsor um is representative Schulz if
she wished to go first to introduce the
bill I would defer to
her representative SCH did not sign up
to
speak I would ask you to speak um Madam
chair I actually did sign up last night
I don't know why it's not on your sheet
but I believed I signed up so this is
this is a learning experience represent
please speak thank you madam chair
um thank you
um I'm here to introduce HB 536 a
one-time death benefit for the
beneficiaries of Public Works
employees this bill was inspired by a
family who lost a father a husband and
they hoped that no other family would
encounter the financial difficulty that
they encountered after their loss of
their family
member um this also is uh a bill that
adds the importance of of um how
dangerous of a job Public Works jobs C
can be uh a year and a half ago a public
works Memorial was installed and
conquered and also recognized that
Public Works employees are First
Responders public servants who put their
lives on the line for our
safety and this bill would uh be
parallel to the ones we passed recently
for other
professions um and it was um passed in a
bipartisan manner in both
Chambers uh from this
committee uh year ago passed 15 to4 and
then the house on a Voice vote in the
Senate uh when it was voted upon on its
own separate from the Omnibus process uh
the vote was was 23
to1 um and so I'm very pleased to bring
this bill back and I'm also pleased that
Susie Nord will also be with us today
from the National Council on
occupational safety and health uh who
brought this family to my attention um
so it's an honor to bring this bill back
and um I hope that it will have your
support thank you thank you are there
questions from the
committee I have a question Madam chair
yes
representa thank you just a moment while
I turn on
my video so that I'm Not Invisible to
the other members and attenders
um I think it's important to know that
uh the
um um that uh the testimony in addition
to what represent Schulz has just
indicated uh spoke about the fact that
uh these people
um she already mentioned they first they
are First Responders and that they are
subject to uh considerable danger um out
on the roadway in many cases are
operating heavy equipment
question so I'm I'm wondering um
what the opposition first question what
was the opposition if any to this bill
when it was heard in our committee last
time I don't remember I do know that the
majority of folks voted for it and I the
four who voted against I don't know I
don't believe there was a Minority
Report
followup follow there are four other
people wishing to testify representative
Schmidt perhaps they will answer your
question questions may I ask it's a
simple question uh what kind of numbers
are we talking about that would be
entitled to this benefit uh if it were
provided uh that's a very good question
uh I would hope
zero uh unfortunately this profession in
New Hampshire uh
approximately one person dies um every
year or
two uh depends you know it's a matter of
accident thank you
representative thank you madam chair um
can everyone hear me all
right okay um I will just add that uh I
I served on the subcommittee that worked
on this bill last term and we had
several meetings to address various
questions um particularly pertaining to
some of the language in the bill uh we
met several times and ended up crafting
a bill that as representative Schultz
said passed this committee then
ultimately passed both bodies House and
Senate unfortunately it got rolled into
one of the Omnibus bills and its fate
became clouded due to that but um I
personally felt that it it really um we
worked on it enough to get it crafted to
the point where it was going to do the
job uh I will state in answer sort of to
representative Schmid's question that we
did hear that there were perhaps one or
two employees a year um excuse me one
employee every year or two who would
fall in into this category and I would
point out further that the language in
the bill states that it's going to be up
to the commissioner of the Department of
Safety to
investigate each one of these deaths to
be sure that the
circum fit the
qualifications that are required by the
bill so it's not just going to be oh
this guy died by the side of the road he
gets the benefit it will be investigated
and part of that is due to the fact that
we heard from the family members uh who
testified previously that that was one
of their concerns they never really got
details about how their loved one died
so in addition to the death
benefit this will provide a little
closure for those
families I think that's about all that I
have um um unless there are further
questions um mother uh excuse me uh
Madam chairman I do have a question if I
may representative
O'Brien go
ahead um thank you for taking my
question uh when you say that the uh
commissioner is g to investigate every
single one will they be Prejudice
because accidents do happen such as uh
in the example if this employee wasn't
wearing his safety vest or something
like that would that deem make him thus
ineligible even though the tragedy did
exist and may beyond the cause of the
safety
vest I would say rep I would say
representative that that would be one of
the
considerations that uh the commissioner
or whoever he assigns to investigate the
accident would look
into um if someone were
negligent and contributed to their own
death I'm sure that would be taken into
consideration our main concern is the
fact that right now at the scene of an
accident you have usually police and
fire um people cleaning up afterwards if
uh a a vehicle comes by and plows into
them they get this benefit but the
Public Works guy who is there sweeping
up the glass in the street gets killed
in the same accident and his family
doesn't get the
benefit thank
you all
right seeing no other
questions
um I'd like to call Marty Marty Carlin
from the retirement
system
and Madame chairman just this is Pam
just to interject while you're sort of
between speakers I I wanted to let you
know that representative Judy has called
in but I'm unable to promote him to the
panelist side because I believe he
called in using the public attendee
phone number so I can enable him to
speak um from where he is or I'm also
sending him I'm hoping he's listening um
I'm sending him his personal uh you know
the information to call in and become a
panelist so I I just wanted you to know
that good morning everyone Madame chair
I am here excellent Jean
Judy
do you have video
capability uh I try but uh I see myself
only but I I don't have any
audio
oh all right thank you we'll have to
talk yes I'm in the pH right
now I I I made it to the participant
side if you want if I should start
speaking now Madam chair this is Marty
from nhrs
please thank you madam chair uh for the
record my name is Marty Carlin uh
representing the New Hampshire
retirement system um just as a technical
matter I just just wanted to let the
committee know you probably know this
from yesterday but there's a little bit
of a lag when you're moving from the
watching side to the participating side
so that's why there was a little dead
time uh for my bik I just want to speak
to there's two parts to this bill House
Bill 536 the first in in most prominent
piece is the uh death benefit and that I
just wanted to clarify that that is not
a New Hampshire Retirement System
benefit that's a separate statute and
just to speak briefly to section two um
which does affect the retirement system
in a very small way this uh section two
of the bill uh removes a offset to a
death benefit paid to a beneficiary um
if they are also receiving a regular a
monthly benefit from workers comp as a
result of the debt
um that uh offset only exists currently
for group one members um it already is
um doesn't exist for group two so this
bill would bring parody to group one and
group two uh you know uh by removing the
offset um from group one uh currently no
one is affected by this um offset um
fortunately um you know there aren't a
lot of line of duty deaths in group one
uh so um you know it wouldn't have a
significant ific fiscal impact um you
know removing this provision and um
typically folks the beneficiaries may be
receiving a workers comp benefit for a
period of time and then uh settle and
receive a lump sum um so it is it isn't
a a very big occurrence for us to apply
this offset um talking to our veterans
in the benefit side they've can probably
count on one hand how many times this
has happened so this is a very minor
change to our law and it only uh creates
parity between group one and group two
i' be glad to answer any questions if
anyone has
any yes represent Roy thank you Tak my
question when you say parody between
group one and group two does that mean
all members of group one or just the
members who would fall under this um
under this Deb
benefit uh thank you representative
the um this this would affect all group
one me all group one members who die in
service of an accidental
death see none thank you very much Mr
car thank you I'd like to call on The
Honorable Susie
nor there we go I was muted um good
morning Madam chair members of the
committee um thank you so very much for
allowing me this opportunity to testify
on health Bill 536 today I um I work for
the National Council on occupational
safety and health as representative
Schultz said and our mission is to
advance worker health and safety through
training education research and
advocacy
um we support House Bill 536 because
while there is no monetary amount which
can compensate families for the loss of
a loved one All Families experience
Financial disruption when a loved one is
killed on the job um and I have written
testimony which I will email to the
committee and I don't really want to
read that however there were two points
in my written testimony that I would
like to make um one is that the state of
New Hampshire has acknowledged for
decades in Department of Labor
administrative rules that public
employers are responsible for ensuring a
safe workplace but but they've only
recently put this responsibility into
statute it's in RSA 277 col 1
B5 um but unfortunately we don't have a
comprehensive system to ensure that
public employers follow generally
accepted safety procedures um as um
organizations in the private sector are
required and because of the lack of
resources devoted to training oversight
and whistleblower protections public
employees are actually at greater risk
of injur injur injury death um and
illness than their counterparts in the
private
sector um and then the other thing that
is in my written testimony that I wanted
to point out is that Public Works
employees are defined as First
Responders in section two of the
Homeland Security Act of
2002 um I think it's section six us code
101 because they provide immediate
Support Services during prevention
response and Recovery operations and so
this bill adds Public Works employees to
the list of First Responders entitled to
the death benefit under RSA
21 you guys probably know this better
than I do so but I really um I wanted to
spend a few minutes this morning talking
to you about my friend Allison Wooten
who could not be here today because of
work um
responsibilities and um she said she she
was tra she travels a lot for work and
she said she would try to listen so I
hope she um is okay with me speaking on
her behalf she did send me an email with
her thoughts on this bill um but what I
wanted to do is to to begin by telling
you how I met Alison Wooten um I met her
in
2017 I was at that time working for the
New Hampshire affiliate of my
organization and um she and her uh
children and other members of her family
came to a memorial dinner that the New
Hampshire Kosh and other Kos groups and
organizations around the country hold um
the last week of April which is
considered workers Memorial week to
commemorate um the specific dinner in
New Hampshire is to commemorate the um
those New Hampshire workers who um have
been killed on the job and we invite
families from or we invite families um
that we can reach it's it's not an easy
task to track down everybody but to
attend a memorial and let them know that
their loved ones are not
forgotten and the thing that I remember
so specifically this was in April 2017
and Allison's husband Tom um was K was
died on the job in July of 2016 so this
is 10 months later and yet what I
remember was this sense you could almost
touch but you were afraid to touch them
because their pain was radiating off of
them they the the pain that this family
felt now you obviously it was somewhat
heightened because of the
circumstances but
um and I remember at the time I had only
really started working with the families
of um workers killed on the job um not
long before and I remember being afraid
to even speak to Allison because I
didn't want to break her she she just
seemed so fragile
and so
um and she didn't stay long I'll admit
and she cried anyway even though I
hardly spoke to her at all and um but
what I've come to learn is part of the
grieving process is to talk to people
about their loved ones and um I have
talked at length with Allison won and
her daughter Samantha about Tom who was
a worker for the Northfield Department
of Public works when he was acting as a
flagger on July 21st
2016 and the public works department
several members were moving a tractor or
moving a trailer um from one place to
another and they did this twice a year
and instead of putting the trailer on
the back of a truck designed to carry
this type of trailer the Department of
Public Works in an effort to save money
carried the trailer between two bucket
loaders like a two trucks like this and
it was you know going down the road and
they had Tom and I believe another
gentleman who were wearing their safety
vests by the way
um flagging traffic around this because
it was a very slow moving obviously and
um something came loose and Tom went to
secure it and he was crushed between the
trailer and the the truck that was
carrying it and
um as a person who works in the field of
workplace safety in health there are a
lot of things that I can say about this
that I won't because it's not
appropriate to this um situation however
make no mistake that Tom's death was a
workplace fatality it was a workplace
trauma and he is has become a statistic
and so um I don't want him to remain a
statistic for you because this bill
really is about people and it's
about how do you make up for the loss of
a human being of a human life
and
um you know Allison and Sam have become
friends of mine and I'm friends with
them on Facebook and because of that
I've seen posts that they have on Tom's
birthday or on the anniversary of his
death and I feel like I know him a
little bit he um was an avid Sportsman
he liked snowmobiling and hunting and
fishing and um he was handy and he and
Alon came to New Hampshire because it
was their dream to live here in New
Hampshire and his job at the DPW was
sort of a semi-retirement job that he
enjoyed a lot it got he got to use a lot
of his skills and abilities and um you
know and he
did yes thank you Miss Nord I muted you
because although this
is fascinating it's not really relevant
to the bill so would you please confine
your testimony to how it affects this
particular Bill thank you very much
certainly Madam chair and I guess I
believe that it is relevant because it's
to understand the loss that
families experience and it's not just a
financial loss although Allison did lose
Tom's income and then when she was in
this situation of trauma where her
husband had just been killed and her
entire life plan has been
disrupted she's asked to make a choice
between accepting workers compensation
payouts or pension benefits or you know
there are so many decisions that come at
these families and not not only are they
in a financial pickle many of them from
the loss of income from the person who
was killed on the job but they are also
in an emotional state that is very
fragile and delicate um as any of you
I'm sure can imagine it would feel to
lose your father your um your spouse
your any loved one really um and so this
bill does not make up for what Allison
lost it can't there is no person and
I've spoken since that time that I met
her I've spoken to
countless um family members who have had
have lost a loved one tragically on at a
in a workplace Fatality and not a single
one of them says yeah I got $100,000
from the state because my husband was
killed but what this can do and Allison
the reason that she asked me what she
could do and I approach representative
Schultz is
that this bill
acknowledges that there
are Financial repercussions and it
acknowledges that the person who worked
for us as a community public workers
public employees um that they have value
and that their work has dignity and that
we as a state appreciate and respect
that and I apologize for my tangent and
I will take any questions I will do my
best to answer
them thank you are there any
questions I don't see any so thank you
very
much thank you madam CH excuse me Madam
chairman can I just interject quickly on
representative Judy I I have muted him
because there was I think there was
sound in his background but
representative Judy if if you would like
to unmute yourself remember star six is
the way to do that and star 9 allows you
to raise your
hand thank you I'm sorry for the
interruption is this this is
representative Broda um representative
Pearson has joined the um hearing
representative Pearson could you please
acknowledge um yourself for the roll
call vote the roll call
attendance acknowledge
I'm not sure how one does so I'm
here and you are where exactly
physically I am physically in the city
of Manchester right now and you are by
yourself I am by myself in my office um
at this time yes that's all you need to
do thank you so much you got
it I'm not accustomed to things starting
before 10 o' with committee work so I
apologize for my
tardiness I apologize for starting
early all right I don't see any other
hands so I will close the public hearing
on House Bill
536 and move on to the hearing on House
Bill 591 excuse me
91 I will call Representative Lang to
introduce the bill and Madam chair is
represent of on I'm going to send now
he's physically in the building I'm
going to send someone over to to ask him
to
stop
representative you do that
sure Madam chair yes representative schz
I see
um uh someone did have their hand up
from the attendees section before you
adjourned that hearing I didn't know if
he was speaking on that bill I believe
he
was I just wasn't quick enough to bring
it to your attention I
apologize yes
I all right
yes there's I don't know if these people
are here for the for 59 536 or for house
91 so I will invite
them to and ask them to tell us which
they are here for there's
two
okay Mr G are which Bill are you here
for uh good morning I'm here for
5:36 I I did register to speak earlier
so um I apologize I didn't raise I got
list attendees I apologize for not
noticing that's
okay please
um please speak on
536 uh thank thank you um Madame chair
members of the committee for the record
my name is Richard gulla I am president
of the state employees uh Association of
New Hampshire and I ask uh for your
support of House Bill
536 uh I thank for bringing this
back last session the reasons why this
bill passed the house last year are even
more evident this year in um in covid-19
world where we are so dependent and
thankful for every first responder who
has stepped up and provided all of us
the services needed to keep us safe
while we work through this incredible
pandemic as written 536 adds Public Work
employees to the list of job professions
eligible for death benefits for those
killed in the line of duty based on the
criteria as laid out in RSA
21 29a the important lines and of
definition added are on page two lines
29 through 34 which clarifies the duties
in which Public Work employees would be
considered for the death benefit clearly
the bill recognizes the work of the
public works and highways Personnel
working in hazardous locations and as
First Responders or working with the
First Responders in construction zones
or other Highway work Highway workers
typically are working within a few feet
of cars and trucks traveling at high
rate of speed in support of police and
other medical First Responders in
accident scenes and other traffic
control emergencies often Highway
maintainers are the first on the scenes
of deadly accidents in New Hampshire I
have listened to the highway workers
retelling of chilling near misses of
cars speeding by Within inches at 75
miles an hour and more while they were
setting up cones to divert traffic away
from a crash site Highway workers
understand the dangers of the job and
they take as many precautions is
possible but they cannot control the
distracted drivers and other accidents
which occur from time to time for our
Highway workers it is just part of the
job they accept House Bill 536
recognizes that as First Responders we
should provide some protections for
those families who have suffered the
loss of a spouse who was killed in the
line of duty Public Work employees are
classified under Homeland Security
Presidential Directive 8 as First
Responders and have been recognized as
crucial to providing safety and support
to our police fire and medical personnel
on our highways and should be included
in providing the same death benefits of
other First Responders I want to thank
you for the time and consideration of
this needed legislation please support
passage of House Bill 536 and provide
our Public Works employees the same
respect and support as we do other First
Responders I thank you thank you Mr
are there questions
committee Madam chair this is
representative groa I would like um Mr G
gulia please to send us his written
testimony I will do
that thank
you all right thank you Mr
gulla thank you good
day okay uh Mr Rodriguez from
DFT yes good morning Madam chair and
members of the committee my name is
David rodrig I'm the director of
operations for New Hampshire Department
of
Transportation um I want to start by
saying the Department of Transportation
strongly supports this bill I will not
reiterate what what others have have
said but a little more
information um do in the public works
industry in New Hampshire are committed
to the safety of all of our
workers however there is no doubt when
conditions beyond our control such as
hurricanes snowstorms and other events
when we are telling everybody else to
stay home we tell our people to come to
work and clear the roads and make our
infrastructure safe for all of the the
people of this state um many of our
people were next to high-speed traffic a
few feet away from motorists to refuse
to slow down move over put their cell
phone down and pay attention to what's
going on on the
road um an industry group leader
environmental health and safety List the
10 top 10 most dangerous
occupations of these jobs Public Works
employees in do
employees do eight of them that we do
eight of them so the the number 10 most
most dangerous job is
Landscaping Town town cities in the
state doot we do plenty of of
landscaping number nine is the
construction trades that that's what we
do day in and day out number eight is
structural steel our our Bridge
maintenance Crews your state do bridge
maintenance crews are working with
structural steel on a regular basis
number seven farming in agriculture no I
won't take credit for for farming in
agriculture that's one of the two we do
not do number six truck drivers we log
millions of miles every every year on
the roads um whether it be plowing or
getting to our work which is on the
roads for us a truck or a vehicle is a
tool to get our to do our job on the
roads not simply to get us from place to
place number five is garbage collectors
our Municipal Public Works Crews um are
all out doing that number three aircraft
Pilots other than one that the the do
who occasionally flies um that's not an
occupation of take a lot of credit for
number two fishing that's one that that
we don't do and number one logging um
that's a big part of our job cutting
trees clearing trees and and so forth so
when we ask why Public Works employees
why are we considering them I want you
to consider two two reasons I said a
more more accurately seven of the 10
most deadly occupations in the world are
part of our routine tasks that's reason
number one reason number two is when
conditions are at their worst when the
rivers are raging the roads are washing
out the floods are coming or have come
or we're in the middle of and we're
telling everybody else to stay home your
public works and do folks are coming to
work to safely close those roads re-root
traffic and do what's necessary to keep
the public safe so I thank this this
committee very much for taking up this
important legislation
$100,000 is a lot of money but it's a
it's a drop in the in the bucket when
you lose what could be the the primary
bread owner of a young family with with
children growing so thank you very much
for your consideration and I'll take any
questions thank you represent Schmid you
have a brief
question Madam
chair did you call my name I didn't
quite hear you yes do you have a
question not a I do uh I I just would
like some
[Music]
collaboration
uh likely to uh be in the category
covered by this
bill I believe Mr gulla would be the qu
answer the question I raised my hand for
him excuse me representative SCH he did
specifically say that it's in the bill
on page two starting on line
29 okay very
good thank you uh Mr
jkin oh
sorry there we go can you hear me Madam
chair thank you thank you very much uh
Jim Durk uh representing asme Council 93
we have about 4,000 members in New
Hampshire including many who work in
public works and I I will be very brief
there's not much I can add uh to what's
been said particularly uh from the
gentleman from uh New Hampshire dot but
if anybody has any doubt as to the need
for this legislation I would encourage
you to take just a brief drive from the
capitl up to the New Hampshire uh uh
Department of Transportation
headquarters well you'll see the public
works
Memorial uh and see the names of dozens
and dozens of professionals Public Works
professionals who have been killed on
the job over many many years I had the
privilege to be at the dedication of
that Memorial and I heard Governor
sonunu uh if he said it once he said it
a dozen times that they are First
Responders uh and look you know the each
occupation each public sector job has
varying degrees of Danger on the job uh
that's clear uh some are higher than
others but the bottom line in our
opinion uh is if you give your life on
the job then your life is worth as much
as any other Public Employee and these
families really need their help we're
actually uh pursuing legislation
throughout our for state region to uh
provide this type of benefit for all
public sector workers uh going back to
what I just said if you give your life
regardless of the level of danger you
face day in and day out if you give your
life in the service of the taxpayer how
can somebody say to a a child and a
spouse of of a deceased employee that
you know one one one person's life is is
worth more than others uh and
unfortunately you know the world we live
in even even in
education uh you know what what about
you know God God forbid in in the case
of a mass shooting in a school what
about the custodian or the teacher that
throws themselves in front of a student
to save their lives so so uh we're
delighted to see this legislation filed
uh and I I thank you for the uh the
opportunity to uh speak today thank you
Mr no other hands I am again
closing
[Music]
5 and reop the hearing on 59 on house 91
and called frch
representative bring in a chair Wheels
um Madam chair I'm so sorry to interrupt
but representative scitec is here so I'd
like him to uh acknowledge um his
presence for the roll call
attendance
here representative SCC are you ready to
um take the minutes for the the bill
this bill would you like me to
continue no I'll
take thank you for your service
representative my
pleasure just carefully set it down
[Laughter]
on I apologize
I'll just stand if
youro I'll leave that over there that's
a way to make an impression
representative
abis going from tragedy to to com we're
just for no was sitting in that
chair I'm just GNA stand that's
okay please pleas thank you my name is
representative Daryl abis I I'm from
Rockingham County District 8 which is
Salem and I'm introducing this bill may
look familiar we did have this last year
I did pass in this committee with pass
recommendation Amendment 181 I believe
it passed the house floor with a roll
call vote of 275 to
41 the reason why I brought this
legislation I filed this bill last year
and refiling it is
we will high frequency of suicide wec in
our First Responders and believe in
2018 it was eight First Responders that
committed suicide in the state of
newford which was much higher than the
TR and this higher rate of suicide
amongst First
Responders has been attributed to
PTSD suicide is a common symptom
attempted suicide or suicide thoughts
are often associated with
PTSD and the reason it's the PTSD is
associated with the high stress First
Responders L work it what this would do
creates that presumption that if the
first responder were to pass away by way
of suicide that he would be considered
related to their
profession there's no difference that if
a first responder suffer a physical
wound but sub subsequently come to that
wound several months later that can be
considered a line of duty death as well
we do have presumptions like um such as
with work workers from involving we
passed Bill a few years ago involving
fire fighters who diagnosed with cancer
because of their exposure to potential
Hazard chemicals there was a presumption
that the cancer was wa
to this policy is was been adopt already
by the United States military and so
it's been implemented and used
before and I understand this bill some
of the concerns I often hear with this
bill and at first glance is that this
bill would reward or encourage suicide
and I believe that's a fair question and
I I don't fault anyone for asking it but
I will say that based on what the line
benefits are if someone were to do the
math I will say that often someone who
is
suicidal from what I understand they
they would not do the ma if they did
from an echnical perspective they
actually
it wouldn't make sense for them to do
that whether it's their pension paying
them or whether they're working they
would make more money alive I don't
believe this would encourage or reward
suicide by by any of this what this does
is it simply provides a line ofy de
benefits to the surviving family of the
first respond
unfortunately circum their
bu I'll answer any
question Bry uh thank you for taking my
question represent um can you tell us
the history of this bill was this year
last year and
how so this was filed I this was filed
last year the second year last term it
was amended in in this committee it did
pass was an off pass with an amendment
recommendation of 181 in the committee
and then we actually voted on this I
believe on the marathon session we had
at 4: a.m. I think we voted on it and
that day it did pass that it was a roll
call and the roll call vote was 275 to
41 it then went on to the Senate it was
never act on in the Senate because of
the so this is just a refiling of that
now this is the filed version with the
amendment and that was my follow this is
the amended version from last yes thank
you
questions so thank you very much
representative this this chair I
apologize thank you I appreciate
it need to testify I do not Madam chair
thank you I just in support of the B
thank
you Chief Goldstein if you'd unmute
yourself are you able to hear me
yes thank you um good
morning good morning Madam chair members
of the
committee for the record my name is
David Goldstein and I am the chief of
police in the city of
Franklin and today I represent the New
Hampshire Association of chiefs of
police and we support HB
91 a historical note and I believe
representative abis may have mentioned
this is that last year under the guise
of HB
1122 your committee passed this uh bill
after a public hearing it also passed
the Full House 275 to 42 but due to co
never made made it to the
Senate also for the record I'd like to
uh lay a little bit of a foundation as
to why I feel I can testify for both the
Chiefs uh as well as law enforcement in
general I've been a police officer for
41 years I have a bachelor's in
psychology a masters in public health
with a concentration of mental health
issues the second Masters in counseling
and a PhD in counseling with a
concentration in criminal justice and
the study of trauma I'm a diplomate and
fellow of the American Academy of
experts and traumatic in traumatic
stress and I'm board certified in
forensic
traumatology I'm a member of the
Southern New Hampshire critical L and
stress management team and peer support
team which deals primarily with law
enforcement as well as being an active
member of the Granite State critical
incident stress management team that
deals with law enforcement Fire EMS and
now we have expanded into hospitals and
work with Physicians nurses and
paramedics I'm a me a member full member
of the international critical incident
stress Foundation I've conducted
Empirical research on the association
between smoking behavior and
self-destructive Behavior at the VA
hospital in Boston I authored and
published a 477 page dissertation
concerning mental health for law
enforcement uh I have authored a number
of peer-reviewed articles in stress
crisis and Trauma and I hold adjunct
positions uh professorships at Boston
University new college and
nhti I'm also an adjunct instructor at
our Academy have been for over 35 years
in the area of stress and crisis as well
as being an adjunct instructor at the
Reading Massachusetts Municipal Police
Academy it is our belief that this is a
very uh laudable and necessary bill and
the research that supports it comes from
the uh perf which is the um Police
Executive Research Foundation the iacp
the Bureau of ger uh justice
Administration New York police
department National Alliance on Mental
Illness Nami that is National Symposium
on law enforcement officer suicide and
mental health also there are a number of
Articles out there researchers and
authors that draw a distinct uh
correlation between the stresses and
strains of police work and all First
Responders and the acts of suicide and
these numbers are growing every year for
example in
2019 we had an all-time low in the
nation of 89 line of duty debts for
police officers however we had an
all-time high of recorded and
authenticated 228 law enforcement
suicides in the
country and is also I believe
representative abis also mentioned the
fact that the United States military has
recognized the necessity of paying out
benefits to survivors and the military
it's a
$400,000 uh payout for uh the survivors
of a suicided uh military
member as far as other uh first
respondents are concerned there's a
study out a recent study that shows that
more firefighters themselves died by
Suicide than in the line of duty deaths
beginning in
2017 it found that 103 firefighters and
140 police officers died by Suicide that
year compared to 93 firefighters and 129
officer line of duty deaths in
2018 in closing we would ask simply that
the committee find this still ought to
pass and I'm happy to answer any
questions the committee might
have fellow a
question um I'm I'm sorry I should have
taken my hand down it was a question for
the last bill the last
speaker is he still around or by any
chance I believe so please ask your
question
um um my question was last last year or
two years ago the um Edna added a
sentence into that bill and um it's
still there in in the current version of
the bill and I just wanted to ask him if
he um felt comfortable with that
sentence or if maybe he he maybe thinks
it it's um can cause some issues in
terms of defining when the benefit
should should
apply Chief
Goldstein I'm I'm actually not familiar
with which sentence you're referring to
but I do have the bill in front of me if
you could give me a specific
reference I'm I'm sorry that question
was intended for the prime
sponsor representative fellows
representative abis specifically said
that he chose to to submit the the
amended version and that's what this is
he supports
it okay thank
you representative Roy has a question
for chief
Goldstein thank you for taking my
question Chief is is it it's my
understanding there's a currently a
death benefit a federal death benefit
for police officers killed in the line
of duty
and if if that's correct does it
currently recognize suicide or not uh
there is a death benefit uh quite
frankly I don't know if it does uh I can
certainly find out for you and uh would
be happy to provide that for the
committee I I appreciate it only because
it would be helpful with us if it does
thank you thank
you seeing no other
questions I'll call on uh Mr Norton
thank you madam chair and committee
members uh my name is Ken Norton and I'm
the executive director of Nami New
Hampshire the National Alliance on
Mental Illness and um on behalf of Nami
I'd like to speak in support of House
Bill 91 just by way of background um I
led the development of Nami New
Hampshire's connect Suicide Prevention
and uh in response to Suicide program we
respond after suicide deaths and we've
trained in over 40 States and 40 tribal
Nations and six countries I've provided
briefings on suicide and suicide
response at the Pentagon and served as a
subject matter expert um to the
Department of Defense the Substance
Abuse and Mental Health Services
Administration the veterans
administrations and others closer to
home I've been involved in the state
legislatively established Suicide
Prevention Council since its Inception
um on the commission on First Responders
and post-traumatic stress and I was on
the Governor's law enforcement um
accountability community and
transparency commission this summer Nami
New Hampshire provides uh 16 hours of
training to all Cadets coming through
the police academy and we're also
currently providing training for um
State Police and Fire and EMS um 40h
hour Crisis Intervention training and an
eight hour Mental Health First Aid
training um through a Federal grant all
of that training includes information
about their own mental wellness and um I
first taught um about suicide of police
not just by police at the police academy
in 2008 we've continued to do that since
then um I uh Chief Goldstein is a tough
act to follow I don't have much more to
add than what he has said other than
that you know the current Department of
Defense policiy to pay a death benefit
um and that that is not narrowly
interpreted to mean the person is on
duty at the time of death and I believe
that's the additional um sentence that
was added to uh by this committee last
year um and you know would reiterate the
information he said about the numbers um
and also uh which are more closely I
think aign for law enforcement but um
we're starting to get a better handle on
fire and EMS and those numbers are quite
high as well and uh just that um First
Responders put risk their lives every
day
um often placing their wellbeing before
that of their of their families for our
wellbeing and families are the hardest
hit by a suicide death and I would urge
you to support House Bill 91 I have
written testimony and I'm happy to
answer that I'll submit I I'll be happy
to answer any questions you have thank
you Mr Norton representative Shu you
have a
question yes thank you madam chair um I
apologize this just a occurred to me and
it it may possibly have been better
directed to the previous speaker but I
was curious uh if Mr Norton could tell
us what kind of access to counseling do
these um employees have uh for PTSD or
whatever issues may be bothering
them thank you for your question
representative it's a great question um
I will do my best to answer but Chief
Goldstein may have some information as
well one of the um one of the biggest
challenges that we face is a culture of
um not asking for help among our um
first responder community and some of
that is um historical in nature relative
to the the jobs that they have and the
perception that if uh they ask for help
that it could negatively impact on their
careers there's been a lot of effort to
change that uh chief Goldstein is uh has
is and has been a leader in our state
around that um but there are um first of
all for anybody that um that is a state
employee for instance in Fire EMS um
there is uh Employee Assistance programs
and I believe most departments have that
as well but more importantly What's um
what's been developed in the last few
years particularly among the law
enforcement Community um but now
starting to see for fire and EMS our
peer support programs where trained um
police officers are not trained not to
be counselors but to be peer support um
for their fellow um fellow officers
there is there was was legislation
passed that provides confidentiality for
that so there's an extensive and
building network of peer support within
the state there are also um specialized
impatient units for instance um mlan
Hospital in Boston has a first responder
um inpatient unit that's exclusive for
um for First Responders needing um
inpatient psychiatric care and then uh
Chief Goldstein also mentioned and he's
been a lead on the critical incident
stress debriefing teams and they will
respond after a critical incident to
provide support and debriefing and again
it's predominantly peers um to uh to
some of these different
departments thank you very much I I know
it's difficult for um particularly
police and firefighters who uh deal with
deaths of um children many times on the
job and I know that's one of the issues
it's very tough to
deal thank you Mr D uh are there any
other
questions seeing none I'd like to call
Mr Wilson
good morning uh thank you madam chair
and the uh members of the committee um
my name is Gordon Wilson I am testifying
in support of HB
91 uh currently I am the coordinator of
the professional firefighters in New
Hampshire peer support team and I've
been a member of Nashville fire rescue
and nashal firefighters I local 789 for
the past 27 years I currently am
assigned to Natural fire rescue station
4 where as where I serve as station cap
I also represent the professional
firefighters of New Hampshire uh on the
commission to study incidents of
post-traumatic stress disorder and First
Responders uh during my remarks I'm
going to focus on firefighters and the
family of firefighters but this in no
way detracts from the serious effect
suicide is having on our other First
Responders and their families I've been
affected both personally and
professionally by firefighter suicide I
have friends that have uh completed
suicide and being being a firefighter
peer supporter I have learned more than
I ever thought I would about firefighter
suicide uh for me HB 91 is not just
about the members who lose to Suicide it
is about their families and helping take
care of a family that is suffered the
devastating loss a family quite often
makes sacrifices due to the nature of
the
job and the uh and the impact it has on
family life I have also witnessed the
toll that suicide takes on other members
of fire department of their fire
departments often times their first
thoughts are of how they can help the
family and to help make sure the family
is supported both emotionally and
financially the passage of HB 91 will
help to alleviate some of the stress
worry and grief of firefighters
suffering with the loss of their friend
and fellow
firefighter knowing that the family will
receive the line a du death
benefit research shows that rates of
PTSD and acute stress are high among
firefighters research research also
shows that firefighters suffer with PTSD
have higher rates of suicides as opposed
to the general population through the
passing of of the PTSD bill for First
Responders and the state of New
Hampshire has
made
sorry are there any
questions can I just uh I just like
would like to add a little bit
more uh as as this time researchers
acknowledge there is very little data on
firefighter suicide and its effects on
family and the community uh this may be
result of stigma surrounding suicide the
PTSD Bill and hp91 will provide much
needed assistance in the short term in
the long term my hope is that by the
state of New Hampshire recognizing the
problem of firefighter suicide through
passing HB 91 more data will be made
available by families and fire
departments for further research into
firefighter suicide this will lead to
better suicide awareness training and
suicide prevention for other states
first for our state's First Responders
uh I urge you all to support HB 91 thank
you thank you Mr Wilson are there any
questions from the
committee seeing none I would like to
call Mr
will Madam chairman I do see
representative Schmidt's hand
up yes indeed thank you mruse for a
moment I just wanted to thank Mr Wilson
for uh the written testimony he provided
uh which was very uh illustrative and
helpful so thank you very much Mr
Wilson I I I did uh
I'll recommend his written testimony to
my colle colleagues on the
committee representa Mr
please thank you can you hear me okay
yes yes thank you madam chair and
members of the committee my name is
Brian will and I serve as the president
of the professional firefighters of New
Hampshire and I'm a captain for the city
of Portsmouth fire department
professional firefighters of New
Hampshire is a state Association that
represents 42 local unions and
approximately 2,000 active and retired
professional firefighters and paramedics
across the GR
State as the preeminent firefighter
organization in New Hampshire we
advocate for the health and safety of
the brave men and women that protect the
citizens of this great state in the fire
service we're routinely called to scenes
of catastrophic incidents involving
severe injuries tragic loss of human
life and property loss I testify before
you today in support of HB 91 relative
to the death benefits of First
Responders who die from suicide uh I
would ask that you see my written
testimony that I have submitted uh more
in depth on this subject um but I do
want to talk about uh a little bit about
the buildt here uh in the fire service
culture we've long been inspected to
portray a tough guy image the iconic
scene of firefighters doing the hard
physically demanding and dramatic work
easily comes to mind and this is
oftentimes contrary to what the men and
women in this fire service are truly
feeling and
experiencing uh the PTSD the nightmares
and the depression just to name a few
all have a cumulative effect on the body
and the
Brain according to the Journal of
Occupational Health approximately 20% of
firefighters and paramedics have
PTSD according to a 2015 Florida State
uh Florida State University study nearly
half of the firefighters surveyed uh
which was about
46.8% have thought about suicide 19.2%
of those had suicidal plans and 15.5%
had made suicide attempts because of
this impact on firefighters we have
worked tremendously hard to provide more
support in this area in 2015 the
International Association of
firefighters known as the iff received
funding from the Department of Homeland
Security to begin developing a
comprehensive evid evidence-based peer
support program for its
members we have created uh a peer
support program much like this here in
New Hampshire uh that's made up of fire
service peers and mental health
clinicians and you heard about uh
Brother Wilson's testimony on this very
subject this focuses on active listening
skills suicide awareness and prevention
Crisis Intervention referrals to local
resources and relationships with local
Behavioral Health Care Providers the
program has been invaluable for many of
our members who've been battling a wide
variety of be behavioral health issues
and uh again I welcome you to look at
our written testimony where you you'll
find more details on this program
specifically uh we do recognize that we
have far more work to do in regards to
awareness and prevention um but we
believe that we've built a strong
foundation with this program
unfortunately uh tragically we continue
to see many of our brothers and sisters
continue to lose their battles with
post-traumatic stress disorder often
times Revolt uh resulting in an increase
in harmful behaviors that include
substance abuse self harm or
suicide we Face the harsh reality that
despite our be best efforts of awareness
and prevention in providing a
a helping hand or a shoulder to cry on
there are simply some instances where
we're unable to make the save and in
these instances our responsibility turns
to the families of th those loved ones
lost those are the very same families
who support their loved one throughout
the many nights weekends and holidays
away from home many times 24 or 48 hours
at a time we owe it to these families to
provide some level of dignity and relief
in their life and while it won't bring
those loved ones back it will help to
ensure those families can begin to heal
the leaders of the professional
firefighters of New Hampshire vow to
continue its fight to educate our
members reduce the stigma surrounding
Behavioral Health and prevent any
further loss of life to this de
devastating illness until such time that
we can win this fight in its entirety we
ask this committee to move to support
hp91 relative to the death benefits of
First Responders who die from suicide um
I will uh be happy to answer any
questions I did just want to address one
question uh that was asked earlier um
about the federal benefit and currently
the the psob federal benefit does not
include stress or strain uh as it
relates to post-traumatic stress
disorder and injuries resulting
thereof thank you good information to
are there other questions from the
committee thank thank you U
Mr thank you you have your hand raised
did you wish to speak on this
Bill yes uh thank you very much uh can
you clear can you hear me
clearly uh my name is Russell KY I am
currently the mental health and wellness
coordinator for the Department of Safety
Division of State Police and that
follows a 32-year career where I retired
as a major um I also am the chair of the
state Suicide Prevention Council uh
which involves many entities and I also
and the board president for the Nami New
Hampshire board of directors so thank
you for hearing me I don't have written
testimony but I do have a couple of
comments I think what we've heard from
testimony uh this morning has been
incredibly um uh informative and I think
it's come from the right people but just
to add a couple of comments um I think
first of all the Department of Safety
Division of State Police is supporting
hp91 and I really want to thank each and
every one of you for the time uh
representative as for putting this
forward uh this is something that
clearly gets looked at and I I was
involved over 15 years ago with putting
a peer counseling unit together with
State Police which was the fair the
first organized peer counseling unit in
in the state at the time and the one
thing that I think is is being left out
that I wanted to mention is the success
stories that we have in treating
post-traumatic stress and in treating
you know uh the incidents that affect
all First Responders and the saves that
we have although we have had many
suicides in my certainly in the last 35
years that I've been involved in being a
first responder and Public Safety there
has been many more that we have helped
and especially in the last few years so
the one thing that I think came of this
that I wanted to make sure everybody
heard was there were several questions
is this something that's going to uh
that's going to push people towards uh
you know death by Suicide is it
something that is going to it's going to
impact people that way you know the
answer in my my humble opinion is
clearly no what we have is we have more
people reaching out for help than ever
we have more help available to people we
have uh not only commissions and I serve
on the post-traumatic stress commission
and we were able to uh to pass some
legislation or help to get some
legislation passed last year with the
help of all of you uh to make a
presumption for uh post-traumatic stress
as related to workman's comp which was
enormous um and when it relates to what
First Responders deal with and what
drives
uh to that desperation to that point
where uh you know death by Suicide is
even something that's considered so I I
just wanted to let you know that there
is a lot going on and the uh Su the
state Suicide Prevention Council many
years ago U and I've been part of it for
over a decade started a law enforcement
subcommittee and we've moved that and
since I have chaired it we have moved
that to the First Responders
subcommittee and we're also going to
make uh we're going to bring in veterans
so veterans and First Responders and the
reason I say that is because there is an
incredible amount of attention that this
is getting Nationwide for the right
reasons and you've heard testimony about
people unable to um to talk about it
having to be the strong people as First
Responders unable to help ourselves all
of those things are true but there is a
pivotal change and I think this bill
being where it is in today's society and
in in not only law enforcement the fire
service uh EMTs are dispatch Personnel
Communications Personnel all of that
matters and there could not be a more
timely uh application of this bill so I
really imploy you to fully support hp91
and know that behind uh all the concern
that comes from this committee and comes
from the representatives that brought
this bill forward are a group of people
both active retired and still in uh the
first responder community that have
recognized the issue that realize what
the solution is and that are working
together uh like they've never worked
together before um so I I implore you to
to support it I thank you for all of the
thoughts I thank everyone for their
testimony today this is this has been an
incredible hearing and to get this to
the point where it has not only last
legislative season but to see it come
back is is really heart warning for
families because in the end that's
really what we're talking about is the
collateral benefit for families uh that
have lost First Responders whether line
of do or death by Suicide and we all
know uh that there's many people left
behind and it affects everyone so thank
you thank you Mr questions from the
committee see none Mr
fet hello uh thank you honorable chair
my name is Ella fet I am the HR
administrator for the New Hampshire
Department of Corrections I'm speaking
on behalf of commissioner Hanks who has
been called away to another matter um
her apologies but I will um speak on her
behalf I have worked for the corrections
field for over 20 almost 25 years now um
and have
seen Corrections come into the world of
law enforcement from where it was years
ago um we are recognize law enforcement
our Corrections Officers our probation
and parle officers along with our
Correctional line Personnel our law
enforcement um they are in the prison
environment they are working with all
the stresses um especially now with this
pandemic um and are impacted both
personally and professionally um by
Suicide and post-traumatic stress and
all the things that we've already heard
in prior testimony um we support House
Bill 91 we appreciate the the fact that
the tragic issue of suicide is being
brought forward and we will do what we
can to be in support and be included in
this Bill thank
you thank you questions from the
committee is there anyone else wishes to
testify on House Bill
91 all right thank you very
much close the
hearing mam chair
yes you ju just for the record um I was
asked to be a co-sponsor on this bill
and I did reply to
S and as we're very much aware right now
OS has become extraordinarily
problematic and these uh Co times we're
in so although I'm not on the bill I
just want the committee to understand
that I was intended to be a
co-sponsor thank
you in that case I'm glad you did not
ask questions very
polite right opening the hearing on
House Bill
69 I do not see the sponsors any of the
sponsors here so would someone from the
committee please introduce
it actually Madame chairman uh
representative Traer I believe is in the
um attendees list though he's not on the
signin sheet he was
earlier oh I wonder if he
left sorry I don't see
him fine then in that case I will
introduce the bill this is House Bill
619 designate Poli and fire dispatchers
as grou two members of the retirement
system I don't know any more than that
but I will say that I have spoken with
representative trer and he has asked uh
this committee to retain it because he
has
found problems with it that he doesn't
think can be resolved immediately he was
working on three different amendments
that I knew of and therefore we wouldn't
be ready to properly evaluate
immediately but he did ask us to
retainment all I have to say on
this we do have other people um Mr
Carlin do you have anything to say on
this
B
Marty
he's on his
way um
Miss Beni did you have anything to say
at this
point uh thank you madam chair and uh
can you hear me
okay yes thank you oh perfect good
morning members of the committee um for
the record my name is Becky banti and I
am the government Finance advisor for
the New Hampshire Municipal Association
and I'm here today to speak in
opposition to HB
619 um while nhma recognizes the very
sign significant responsibility carried
out by dispatchers across the state and
the critical Services they provide uh
particularly over the past year nh's
legislative policy positions oppose any
expanded benefits that would increase
current or future employer contribution
costs and just referencing the newly
certified employer contribution rates
which become effective on July 1st
dispatchers are currently classified in
group one employees which is uh
14.06% of payroll is the employer cost
and that would increase if they were to
be included as group two police to
33.88 per of payroll or for fire to
32.99 per of payroll uh which is more
than double the current employee rate
taking these rates and applying them to
annual ra wages which could range um an
estimated of40 to $60,000 for
dispatchers The increased cost to a town
or city resulting from this legislation
would range from 7,800 to 12,000 per
year per individual dispatcher and while
the impact of this bill would be
relatively minimal to a smaller
municipality it could be significant uh
very significant for larger cities who
have a number of both police and
firefighters
dispatchers but more concerning to nhma
is that by expanding the positions
currently qualified in the
re of police and fire for this one
position uh dispatchers now it could set
a precedent and open the door for future
expansion of the group two membership
which of course would result in even
greater future additional employer cost
and with the loss of the state's share
of employer costs municipalities would
be required to assume 100% of the
increase in costs and for those reasons
uh we respectfully request you to vote
HB 619 and expedient to legislate that's
that's all I had to say thank you very
much for your
time any questions from the committee
represent lro I didn't have time to do
this research on my own I apologize for
that it's a simple question what's the
defining feature of a Group Two member
as opposed to a group one member group
one members um include police and
teachers I'm sorry I said police group
one are employees of um employees and
teachers group two are police and
fire
follow Associated members of fire
departments such as maintenance
personnel and dispatches are explicitly
excluded from two may I follow up and
thank you for taking my question by the
way way but what is the I'm not asking
for a list of who's included in this
group I'm U I'm really after what are
the defining features of that group is
it risk to life is it uh hazardous
materials that's what I'm trying to get
at uh I I it's defined in RSA
100a paragraph
7 which defines the requirements for
group one okay I'll we'll discuss it
after the he thank you
all right um thank you
m uh Mr
jerkin thank you madam chair everybody
hear me
okay uh once again Jim Durkin
legislative director foras me uh 4,000
public sector workers are under our
Union in New Hampshire including about
50 emergency dispatches working in 12
New Hampshire municipalities in one
County and uh I'm here today on their
behalf to ask for your support for HB
619 which you know essentially would
reduce the amount of years that'd be
required to work and what is widely
recognized as one of the most stressful
jobs in public service as a union
representing hundreds of Dispatchers in
four New England states we often refer
to these professionals as the first of
our First Responders that's because they
are the very first people responsible
for helping others during the most
difficult tragic uh moments of their
lives Retirement Group classifications
and the justifications behind them vary
from state to state but in general
they're based on physical abilities and
emotional stress levels that ultimately
lead to very real physical problems and
the goal is to provide people with an
opportunity to retire and enjoy some
decent healthy years before the toll of
the job results in debilitating health
problems that impacts their quality of
life and ultimately shortens that life
uh quick quick example in Massachusetts
our Corrections Officers are allowed to
retire with 50% of their pay after 20
years regardless of their age and the
idea is to get them into a new
occupation before they hit their 50s
because if they work Beyond 55 most are
dead before they hit the age of 62 and
but you know most people understand that
Corrections and police endure high
levels of stress they don't need to be
convinced but few realize how much
stress our dispatches endure every
single day on the job uh over time that
emotional stress again manifest itself
in the form of physical ailments heart
disease high blood pressure it's because
the day is never routine or the same
within a single hour they can be found
handling an opioid overdose a fatal
crash and a house fire then when the
call ends they're required to do it all
over again every single day and they
don't just take and root the call
they're required to calm the caller as
quickly as possible and when needed
they're required to give immediate
life-saving advice over the phone until
emergency Personnel arrive they spend
their entire shifts dealing with people
in the most Panic moments of their lives
and those people's lives are dependent
on how quickly and efficiently they
react their dispatcher a few seconds of
delay or hesitation can mean the
difference between life or death so in
closing I want to say that a lot of our
dispatchers wanted to be here to share
some of their stories but most are
either on the job now resting up for the
second shift or sleeping after a long
shift so I'll end with one story told to
me years ago that still haunts me to
this day uh this particular dispatcher
took a call from an elderly gentleman
who awoke from a fire alarm and called
911 to ask for help because his only
exit from his third four apartment was
blocked by the
fire the dispatcher told me he knew
there was no hope for the man so he
stayed on the line with him he listened
in horror and Agony to his screams until
the fire took him and the line went dead
and I'm sorry to have burden you with
the story but I felt compelled to tell
it with the hope that it'll give you
some understanding as to why this
legislation is needed and why these
brave men and women need your help and
uh you know in particular to to to
stress that this shouldn't be about cost
uh it really really shouldn't so I thank
you for your time your consideration and
also all of you for your continued
dedication to Public Service during
these extraordinarily difficult
times you have a
question
fellows uh thank you um Mr Durkin can
you tell me if there are any other
states that put Dispatchers in the same
uh category as police and fire for uh
retirement uh not that I'm aware of in
our region representative uh we are
pursuing this we have quite a lot in
Massachusetts uh we came very close
actually the last time around to moving
them uh into what we call group two in
Massachusetts which is not in
Massachusetts it's group four for police
and fire we got four groups police and
fire in group four state police are the
only ones in group three and then group
two which Cuts five years off the age uh
and then group one is is is everybody
else um we we we made tremendous
progress uh in the in the last session
but again you know with the uh with the
pandemic a lot of a lot of good
legislation stalled out across the
country uh but they are uh thank you you
know they thank you
representative Schmid do you have a
question I do Madam chair thank you very
much uh Mr Durkin uh if I understood
correctly uh the prime sponsors asked
for this bill to be retained because it
has some problems that is that uh is
this going to be going forward Madam
chair I'm not I'm not hearing you well
Madam
chair would be it and work on it over
the summer when we can get progress this
sort of
meeting okay I recommend you stay on top
of this Mr Durkin certainly
representative thanks very much you're
welcome are there any other
questions seeing
none Madame chairman the representative
Traer is has has uh rejoined us and
we've labeled him by his full name so
he's easier to find on the
list thank
you points you'd like to make to the
committee good morning I could not hear
you on the last comment or
question ask whether you to speak to the
committee considering we've already
heard your request
to no at this point basically I am going
to ask that the bill be retained I feel
that a little bit more research needs to
be done before we bring the bill
forward thank you very much thank
you no one else has their hands raised
so I will close the
hearing on House Bill
619 and open the hearing on House Bill
274 and call Representative O'Brien who
is the Prime
sponsor
representative
O'Brien can't hear you
in that case representative Cushing is a
co-sponsor
here I don't pushing
either Madam chair can you hear me now
you are
okay thank you uh Minor Adjustments I
apologize uh thank you U Madam chair for
recognizing me and good morning to my
fellow uh committee members on
Edna uh I'm happy to serve with you and
I'm also a proud sponsor of uh House
Bill
274 what let me cut to the chase because
the hour is late but basically what
we're talking about here
is trying to get back what was once part
of the retirement system as you all know
they used to
contribute
35% you got wean down in tears go down
to basically zero when that occurs and
you don't really fix the whole complete
structure that means somebody's going to
make up to
35% and those people that are making it
up have been some of the stakeholders
themselves members of that are paying
currently paying into the retirement
system but also this came down to each
individual City and town so that they
would be responsible to pay uh that
35% now I can speak about the city of
Nash this has brought up uh about a $2
million charge
uh to pay into the uh the pension system
where does that money come from well
money as we all know money doesn't grow
from trees so it comes from the
taxpayers so one could say by the state
alleviating the responsibility of
35% has cost an additional tax to the
taxpayers of all communities throughout
the
state it is the hope of complying with
this bill
that uh uh we can alleviate that let's
look what cities and towns and all
across our state are going through uh I
can say in the that's common Al all
cities and towns are paying into this
but also I can speak for Manchester and
ashaa the homeless population the opioid
problems the other different things that
come up that kind of eat into the
taxable structure and now on top of it
you got to pay into the retirement
system so therefore the intention of
this to sum it all up is trying to get
the state back into realizing that
municipalities need the help with the co
that'ss around right now municipalities
need a relief this is no longer anything
that municipalities can absorb they need
to help to get back to some degree and
hopefully within the 15% that uh will
alleviate some of the municipal burden
into the retirement C and uh Madame
chair if I can ask I would uh hope you
have on your speakers list uh the people
that can really get into the Weeds on
this much better than I can would be his
uh honor the mayor of the city of Nashua
James dcas and his CFO John Griffin so
if you could recognize him at some point
when you're ready to speak would greatly
appreciate it and I'll
conclude I look for representative for
Mr John just because he signed up to
speak he doesn't appear to be an
attendee so we will wait maybe he's not
with us are you if I may Madam chair are
you seeing uh CFO John
Griffin he didn't sign up to
speak okay uh may I ask a little Grace
this is all kind of new to us uh he is
the CFO for the city of Asher a
true of the numbers if you can extend
youate the courtesy I would appreciate
it representative Brian after the people
who have signed up have spoken I will
ask for other members and he has been
can ask hear from him at that time and I
graciously thank the chair thank you um
I I see Nash a May listed in the
attendees then I will I will call on him
first though we will hear from Mr Carlin
from the reement
system thank you madam chair um for the
record again my name is Marty Carlin
representing the New Hampshire
retirement system um just as a
housekeeping matter I didn't have any
testimony on House Bill 619 but did want
to mention that uh we sent a handout uh
that uh Pam was circulating last night
uh maybe ause to the committee if the
bill is retained
uh as to House Bill 274 uh nhrs has no
position on on this bill I signed up
more for informational purposes and we
we have a handout on this one uh NHS
Bill brief HB 274 if you have that uh
with you it just provides a little bit
of a background history on the state
contribution subsidy for local costs of
teachers police and fire uh which was
uh eliminated back in 20 12 I believe um
and also just a summary of the fiscal
note that's attached to the bill uh
which would show the state cost uh at a
5% contribution for local employers uh
for those three member groups um this is
not an Actuarial bill or has will have
no impact on employer contribution rates
for nhrs uh this is simply somebody else
will be paying uh you know some a share
of the local cost to nhrs but the you
know the total net amount coming in will
be the same uh I'd be glad to answer any
questions anyone may
have I don't see any questions from the
committee
uh Becky Ben
[Music]
Beni
yes thank you again Madam chair and
members of the committee for the record
I am Becky banti government Finance
adviser for the N Hampshire minicipal
Association and I am here to speak in
support of HB 274 and I have also
submitted to the committee written
testimony restoring the state's share of
employer costs for police teachers and
firefighters has been a longstanding
policy of nhma While most political
subdivisions in New Hampshire also
participate in the retirement system for
their
employees participation is mandatory
under statute for police fire and
teacher members the state's contribution
which was originally 40% in 1967 before
being reduced to 35% in 77 was also
mandatory the legislation amending the
statute in 20111 to eliminate completely
the state's 35% share for police fire
and feuture employer cost has been one
of the largest fiscal impacts upon
municipalities in Des in decades in just
the eight-year period from 2013 to
2020 the elimination of the state share
has amounted to an increase in the
employer contributions required to be
paid by political subdivisions of over
$720
million the current 6 billion unfunded
liability which was amortised over 30
year period ending in
2039 is required to be paid through the
employer contributions and the state
also had a 35% share in paying this
long-standing
obligation the elimination of the state
share of the employer cost has
downshifted this state level financial
responsibility to the local taxpayers
whose Municipal County and local school
property tax rates have all increased
over the past eight years to raise the
property tax revenue necessary to fund
the additional 729 million in Municipal
School District and County employer
costs which are mandatory for police
firefighters and teachers although a 5%
contribution which is estimated to be
17.66% share estimated to be
12362 million this bill would provide
some immediate and needed relief to
political subdivisions and help offset
the major rate increase which becomes
effective July 1st we respectfully ask
that you vote in favor of HB 274 and
again thank you for your
time are there any questions from the
committee seeing none mayor
dones um well thank you madam chair and
members of the committee I uh see um
Mike O'Brien representative Mike O'Brien
who's also on city government with me so
uh I'm glad to be before
you we are asking here that the state as
you just
heard uh return to contributing a small
amount towards Municipal
pensions now the problem here is that
the cities and towns across New
Hampshire are the victims of a broken
promise the way the state retirement
system was formed the way way the reason
that so many municipalities are in the
system and and basically all
municipalities are part of it is that
when the is that the state
promised that in order and induce the
communities to enter the system by
promising that if the communities
entered the state would pay first 45
well 40% as you just heard would pay
40% and of course that was
a very an attractive inducement and most
in all cities and towns basically joined
the state retirement system that was
reduced to 35 but that was you know a
very modest reduction and probably
didn't upset too many people or at at
the time back in the back in the
70s uh then as you've already heard uh
both from the previous speakers in
around 2011 the amount of the
contribution was reduced to zero this
has worked an incredible hardship on
cities and towns across the state the
result of a big increase in
costs um has meant always means I think
when you're dealing with local budgets
always means a combination of a tax
increase with a reduction of
services so there's no question that we
you know not only have local taxes been
driven up because of this but also
quality of
schools police protection and other
other services provided by cities and
towns has also been affected again most
cities and towns handle a big increase
by kind of
balancing uh some tax increase with some
reduction in
Services now what has happened is that
you'll hear more about this this
afternoon but that the retirements and
and so over the years as a result of
decisions made at the state level not by
the local communities somehow the system
got
underfunded and this was a result of
probably making decisions to extend
benefits the system couldn't afford uh
to not you know maybe the management of
assets maybe the U not charging back you
know some years ago what should have
been
charged and so as a result of the
decision to reduce
the assumed rate of return which is that
that part of it is mandatory you know
they they have to use fiduciary
responsibility to make that decision but
as a result of being of that decision
being made communities are now being hit
come July 1
2021 with another huge increase for us
in Nashville and I just give you our
figures not because we are different or
more important or anything else but just
to give you some this is the numbers I
know our increase is four4 m million do
which is already a 2% uh tax increase
for the taxpayers of nashille on top of
a reduction of school aid uh so this is
this is a very big hit and
the this hit comes at a at exactly the
wrong time I we were struggling with the
covid-19 The increased costs decreased
revenues as a result of that pandemic uh
the prospect that real estate values in
the commercial areas
could certainly go down as a result of
the pandemic raising residential
property taxes so this is working a huge
hardship and of course we have
additional costs related to The Learning
Gap that is resulting because aren't
going to school things like that so the
5% bill which you have before you would
not completely offset the increase that
uh is being made by uh as a result of
the reduction in thetive return it might
reduce that impact by about uh you know
half so for Nashville maybe we would the
increase would be two million rather
than four but as I said at the beginning
all of the cities and towns whom you
represent are the victims of a broken
promise again I'll just give you Nash's
figures that broken promise has already
cost the the citizens of Nasha $74
million
uh money that could be I mean we could
the new Middle School we cash almost if
we had that money back so we're asking
some you to help us with some relief
here uh taxpayers and communities across
the state really need this and of course
I am certainly available for questions
if anybody has
any are there any questions from the
committee
representative
Pearson thank you madam chair Mr
Mayor I know you have not been
mayor for a substantially long time but
do you recall the city of NASA ever
objecting in the
1990s when the bill seemed to go
away when what when the bill from the
state when the state legislature decided
to give a moratorium on the bill to into
the pension system in the 1990s I mean
this this current situation we're in is
is a combination of of faults and errors
if you will and well my my answer is
first of all I wasn't in city government
then but right I mean in a way why
should they I mean they're relying on
the state of New Hampshire to run this
system we're not part of the running
they say that they don't need money what
how would anyone question that so um
yeah that was a huge huge mistake and
taxpayers at the
time I'm sure benefited from it but that
was 25 years ago and um again what are
we you know what what communities across
the state are told this the retirement
system doesn't need money by the people
who supposedly know what they're
doing um we don't have a sex separate
Actuarial analysis or anything like that
we don't you know who what do we know so
okay um you don't need the money so why
charge us but so that that mistake was I
don't think you can blame the
communities for a decision like that
made at the state
level Mr Coran
thank you madam chair I hope you can
hear
me yes great um my name is Dennis Corgan
and I'm uh testifying as a member of of
the public opposed to HB
274 I'm also speaking on behalf of the
Granite State taxpayers I'm a board of
directors member of GST and we are the
oldest Statewide taxpayer group in New
Hampshire I'm a retired pension actuary
and I was appointed by Governor cunu to
be on the uh desial Commission in 2017
as a public expert member when we
studied the New Hampshire retirement
system and recommended legislative
changes we are here to oppose HB 274 and
I've sent uh some written testimony but
I mistakenly sent as an attachment I'd
be glad to resend that as a body of an
email if that's more convenient for you
we have two main concerns about uh this
bill the first is that by shifting part
of the cost of funding these these um
Municipal pensions to the state there'll
be inevitably a tendency to increase
benefits on the part of the plan
sponsors the
towns because uh in that way um they can
uh increase benefits without having to
pay the full value of uh the F the full
cost of these
improvements the second uh item I'd like
to mention is that uh the increase from
a 0% State share to a 5% State share is
a is an enormous step but the ratchet
effect will inevitably mean that moving
from 5% to larger uh percentage shares
will come they'll be very difficult to
resist the calls for that and I noted um
representative o'ban was already talking
in terms of
15% so I would urge the committee to
vote in expedient to legislate on this
bill and I'd be glad to take any
questions thank
you other
questions I don't see any thank you Mr
thank you Mr
Griffin yes uh Madam chair can you hear
yes thank you thank you me Madam chair
and members of the committee my name for
the record is John L Griffin I'm the
Chief Financial Officer for the city of
Nashua and I'm pleased to prepare these
remarks for you folks and we'll follow
up with an email as indicated uh by m
dones we are in difficult times for two
reasons one is the increase in the
employer rates for the city pursuant to
the reduction in the assumed rate of
return that number as projected in
fiscal 22 is a $4.4 million increase so
if the committee and the legislature put
in a 5% contribution that would be 1.2
million off that 4.4 so that's the
specifics in that regard a
15% uh contribution would be 3.7 million
not quite equal to the U increased
pursuant to the reduction of the return
uh assume rate of return uh another this
is a big item for the city of Nashua we
anticipate spending about 25 million
this year in contributions for police
fire teachers and
employees number is going to be 29
million plus in fiscal
22 and as mayad Don just indicated every
2 million increase in costs or decrease
in revenue is
1% on the tax rate so we're struggling
at this point in time given the pandemic
and um any any relief that we could get
would certainly uh help us weigh those
balances that we make every year between
the provision of services and the
affordability of the tax rate for the
taxpayers so with that uh Madam chair
I'd be H happy to answer any questions
that you may have thank
you
uh I'm believing I'm hearing you calling
on me uh representative Maguire um so Mr
Griffin thank you for your testimony um
the figures you quoted would be interest
to you interest to us are you planning
to or have you already submitted them in
writing I I will be submitting them uh
representative Schmidt thank you yeah
thank you very much that's appreciated
i' like to mention to the committee that
I just noticed I've had about a dozen
pieces of written testimony on these
bills in my
email sent it to the entire committee so
that should be uh available to all of us
Mr Coran did you have an additional
comment Adam Cher what is the where's
the location of your microphone because
you are extraordinarily hard to
hear I'm sorry I couldn't understand
you I'll I'll try to do it without my
accent the location of your
microphone Carol it's very difficult to
hear you it's too far away from
you okay is that
better much better better you for for
the
feedback Madam chair if I can um just as
a matter of feedback uh I don't know
about anyone else but I can hear the
folks who are testifying remotely much
better than any of you who are speaking
from the committee
room uh I don't know if that's something
that the tech folks could work on but
just like I said as a matter of feedback
if if everybody else that's uh listening
in remotely agrees with that I think
it's something that hopefully can be
remedied 100% agree thank you did um
Madam Madam chair I would also like to
ask that um because the remote people
are so so much louder I have to turn the
volume down when I'm listening to them
and then to hear people in your room I
have to turn it up again so if you could
when you ask the if you say when are
there any more questions for the speaker
if you could wait like you know 10
seconds or so to give people just a
chance to you know hear what's going on
and to uh get their hand up that would
be useful too thank you I will have the
tech people come in and balance the
volumes we had to boost the volume of
the remote people earlier because we
couldn't hear you
so it's it's a learning
experience since there don't appear to
be any more comments on House Bill 274
I'm going to close the hearing we resume
at5 on the ACT House Bill
130 and we will attempt to get our
technical issues solved in the meantime
thank you
all
Madame chairman I think I see you there
but um you're muted so you can't talk to
me but Scott Kelly's on his way he
should be there in a
minute
I don't
want Morning
has okay how do I sound
here it sounds good it's certainly not
um too loud at all but it's I I could
hear most of what was going on it's just
that um I think it's sometimes a
representative Maguire might have turned
you know turned your head or you know
sort of turned away from the mic but
when you spoke right on it it was loud
and
clear I will have to behave better I
know it's it's and you're looking around
at the you know hands in the room or
whatever else it's it's um it's
definitely a a learning process okay so
so you will share your screen with the
out sign that's what I was about to do I
can you hear me right here I can loud
and clear
or loud and clear but but you know
you've got a nice strong voice too right
well I move the
room mic right front as well she'll have
both mics
okay still good that's
good one thing we need to talk about
Scott um we had our first testimony from
a from an in-person member you know a
member of another committee came in and
testified and he didn't have we didn't
have a setup for him to testify so he
just sort of stood near the table and he
was the hardest speaker for me to
hear okay so I don't know what the
solution to that is I'm just throwing it
out where we are having you know he was
a chairman of I think criminal justice
and they're meeting in another room this
morning so he came in to to um speak to
his bill in
Edna okay um so the committee yesterday
put a table out in the middle and when
somebody wanted to speak they the table
and I do
same commission have a tblop in the
front like right
[Music]
here
CL
for
e
okay
testing
[Music]
hello
everywhere
oh
okay
you know if they broke for lunch or yes
broke for
lunch
e
hi Pam can you hear me just finish test
s oh sorry I was I was doing something
else Scott okay how how can you hear
me I can hear
you that's where representative abbis
was standing more or less right there
maybe a little more to you know towards
the
center you have any other people coming
from another committee you know we don't
know ahead of time I at least I don't um
you know I didn't expect
that
I think the chairman knew about it but
um she I hadn't
heard I'll set up a station
anyway that would be perfect that would
be
great I
mean yeah I I don't know I don't want to
mess up the the mic system especially if
it doesn't happen again but
it but it could
I
okay so all the sound fine
now it sounds great where you're
standing I think people need to project
some you know I don't know if that's
part of
it right I move mic's closer to some
people so I
think great thank you so much
Scott
okay so you think you're all set with
me yes I am thank you okay I'm gonna
mute
myself
e
I'm perfectly happy with having the
print out prior to uh
uh from 30 minutes before FL that seems
to work yeah I mean there was like
complaint that somebody had registered
and they weren't on the list it's
because he registered late so yeah Don
just didn't register as Donas he
register National mayor and my eyes just
skip right over that right and you know
like representative travier came on at
Doug
T you know I didn't know his first name
this is so reminiscent of all the
headline hollering about the
vaccinations you got millions going on
what do you expect yes some are going to
thought out die that's too bad but come
on I yeah it's I think we've got a a
decent system and people are learning
and it'll get
better wonderful
yeah all
right here the copies of 130 oh thank
you Pam have we solved the the technical
problems from this
morning I believe so they were in trying
to equalize the
volumes my problem was not put right by
the microphone is my problem and we'll
do what we
can right well if it's as simple as
moving the microphone closer to you that
would be great I mean you are hard to
hear if you're if if for for those of us
who are on the
zoom we can hear each other fine but we
just can't hear you too well and Terry
we can hear fine but we but he does talk
very much so it doesn't make any
difference yes well
it's I can hear Tony I can hear Tony
leus pretty well
too and and the there are a bunch of the
the new people I don't know where they
are I don't see them on the zoom but I
can hear them every once no while but
one of the things that's not happening
is the the speaker is not is not popping
up on the the main screen all the time
with that's one of your settings in your
Zoom you
have and and speaker mode I'm seeing
those so yeah I think that's something
with
your contr peter I can't
help okay well I I didn't know I I had
an option there forgot I got my video
on so but they're not talking much
anyway so it's not a big
problem you want to start right at 1:15
Carol I hope
so okay as far as you're concerned
you're going to start I'll be ready at
150 that's where the extra few pounds
are
I didn't realize that move over you like
I guess
I
yeah
I've got them you got them already this
one just
arrived is this 130
yeah yourself I'm very
organized impr all printed out in
sequence with my nasty comments already
already okay well I
didn't I knew they would be here so I
didn't do that it it appears that
representative Pearson has developed the
need for a shade
and possibly a
dentist I thought maybe he had plastic
surgery that hadn't gone so
well certainly hope representative Roy
comes back because I'm a co-sponsor and
I can't run this
meeting
a there he
is okay
Terry I'm a
co-sponsor
prepar
actually
[Music]
for
Madam chair I congratulate you on uh
scheduling this has allowed me enough
time to go out and clear my driveway of
snow much much better at noon than at 8
o'clock in the
morning yes I was hoping we would be
able the uh the last bill actually took
less time that I
expected
yeah
am okay this time I'm going to open up
the hearing on House Bill
130 and I'm going to recogniz
representative
sh thank you Mr Vice chair um
I introduce well first of all I should
say I'm representative Diane Shu Premier
Mac 20 for getting the
formalities of doing these things um and
I am here to introduce House Bill
130 relative to Administration by the
retirement system of certain Health Care
premium
deductions um I am also at this time
presenting a companion Amendment if you
will uh I introduced this bill at the
request of the retirement system to have
the legislature
determine uh the question it's sort of a
which came first the chicken or the egg
thing uh apparently there has been a
spat between these two agencies for a
while as to whose deductions should come
first uh the bill as you see it has the
retirement system in the first position
and the amendment which you should have
all received through email uh has the
department of administrative services in
the first position Mr Carlin spoke to me
about this bill actually two years ago
and uh I attempted to put it as an
amendment on a bill last year but as we
all know last year got sort of
bamboozled
uh so I'm bringing it forward as a clean
bill this year and it's going to be up
to the legislature to determine who
should Prevail and I believe that there
are representatives from both agencies
here who can present their respective
positions and then we will go from there
so unless there are any other questions
or any other co-sponsors wish to speak
um you may proceed with those
folks are there any questions from any
of the
members see none the chair will
recognize Marty Carlin from the state
retirement thank you Mr chair um for the
record my name is Marty Carlin
representing the New Hampshire
retirement system I'd like to thank
representative Shu for introducing uh
the bill and the amendment essentially
although um we're very close and work
very well with Das I wouldn't categorize
our disagreement as a an interpretation
as a spat but um I do do want to briefly
explain um you know what the medical
subsidy is and what the what the issue
in question the bill is addressing um or
the bill seeks to address um basically
if you're not familiar with it we
covered it a little bit in the
orientation presentation the medical
subsidy isn't an insurance benefit uh
rather it's it's a premium offset um
applied uh uh if the retiree is paying
for insurance from their former employer
out of pocket um it works a little bit
different for the state because uh State
retirees are insured through the state
so um you know and the plan was closed
for group one members uh about more than
a decade ago for for state employees
actually back in 2004 uh for um Public
Safety uh group two um there are some
people who are still active who will
qualify for the benefit when they retire
but it is a closed group so essentially
this benefit U will eventually no longer
exist once the eligible membership uh
population is gone um the question um
and our the subsidies was originally
introduced back in the late 80s early
90s so the question is in I believe in
2009 the state uh the legislature put a
a Premium cost Associated for State
retirees and um you know our
longstanding administrative practice was
to pay the subsidy amount prior to
taking any authorized deduction uh
there's there's a phrase in the statute
uh 100 A52 that says shall pay the cost
and um you know we we read that as an
obligation for an HRS uh to pay the full
subsidy um our understanding and and I
um I'll I'll leave the details to the
folks at T I don't want to speak for
them um you know but there's another
piece of the statute that refers to
which shall the U the phrase which shall
be in addition to a notwithstanding any
amounts payable to the retirement system
um to uh put the put the deduction ahead
of the subsidy application so really um
we brought this question to our Board of
Trustees and they authorized staff to
seek clarifying legislation on the
intent of when they um the state Rey
premium is applied before or after the
subsidy is applied uh to the cost uh we
truly don't have a specific uh a a
outcome or position on this bill we're
just looking for administrative Clarity
moving
forward any questions from the members
[Music]
Mr thank you yes I I was just curious
Marty if um the retirement system has in
fact
searched uh the section of the RSA that
authorizes your position uh as to
legislative intent at the time it was
adopted um I believe our legal folks
looked at that and didn't didn't see
anything in the record indicative either
way thank
you
any further questions from the
members I'm going to recognize myself
for a quick question could you explain
um just briefly what the plus or minus
is to the employee on
this uh it it it for the state side it
may be U invisible it's it's going to
depend because typically uh retire
insurance premiums are higher than the
subsidy amount the subsidy amount was
frozen back in um 2008 so um it's really
um you know if if if there's a case
where the premium is close enough to the
subsidy that it would cover the full
cost of the benefit then the if they
were assess the state premium they would
be paying some out of pocket for that um
you know if if the uh premium was
applied first um you know for for
anybody who's on the predicare health
insurance which is is more more costly
plan um the spread between the actual
cost of the benefit and the subsidy is
is quite
wide I see representative fellows would
like to ask a question um yes thank you
I just wanted to ask if someone could
resend the amendment because I don't
seem to find it
anywhere if anyone has that send it to
appreciate I can look for it in the file
and and send it to you representative
fellows yeah I don't need it right this
second thank you
sure any further questions
this if not chair who else wish to speak
on
this no one else has signed up
specifically to
speak Madam chair I think um the folks
from admin Services uh may may were
planning to speak on it last I spoke to
them so they may be in the waiting
room anyone from admin Services is in
the waiting room and raise
hand I had made uh Katherine ke aware of
this and she emailed me back that they
would be
present okay the chair is going to
recognize Charlie Arling
house
yeah can you hear
us doesn't look
like would you like me to promote him to
a panelist that's what's required for
him to speak yes
please looks like Joyce Pitman will also
be pushing his
feet
go ahead and St I believe
you you should be able to
unmute oh how's that thank you oh very
good thank you um the wonders of modern
technology um I'm Charlie Arling housee
I'm the uh Commissioner of
administrative
Services um and uh we agree with the uh
with the intention of the bill which is
to clarify the
uh uh clarify the matter um which I uh
like Marty would hesitate to
characterize as a spat as much as a mild
disagreement which we have from time to
time um my understanding is that you're
likely to refer this to a subcommittee
in which case we would like very much to
work on the language um we want to do
what we can to preserve the um the in
addition to and notwithstanding language
um I want to make a couple of points one
is I want to make it clear that today's
discussion is about sources of revenue
to the state retiree health
benefit and it is not about local reti
health benefits or any other
subdivisions this is merely about the
state plan that if you're if you're a
member or participant in something else
this is not related to that or related
to you it is merely about the revenue
sources to the state
sources for the retire Health Plan the
largest one is a uh significant general
fund appropriation but there are a
couple of other ones and we're talking
about two of them today one is the
medical subsidy and the other is the
premium contribution in 2001 the medical
subsidy was created and for those of you
who are as old as I am and can remember
the 2001 budget debate you will remember
it was an enormously contentious time um
because we didn't have much money tell
me if you've heard that story before um
and as uh as part of a bunch of
compromises there was a medical subsidy
created um which was about $8 million at
that time um to the plan and it it is a
I'm going to make this point it is a
subsidy to the plan as opposed to a
subsidy to the individual this is a uh
this is a a a transfer uh we send money
to the retirement system they send money
back and it is revenue to support uh the
sustainability of benefits for the
healthc care plan um in 2009 when
premium contributions started being
charged um the language and I I believe
we actually helped the legislature write
the language and was probably Linda
hodon at the time who people will
remember um And to clarify that this was
an additional source of Revenue they
inserted into the law the phrase um the
retire premium would be in addition to
and
notwithstanding uh the medical subsidy
that is to say that that I think that's
actually fairly clear language in
addition to and notwithstanding
our position as a department has been
that that means that it should be in
addition to and
notwithstanding and um that's the source
of our disagreement with the retirement
system where they think it should not be
an addition to and notwithstanding and
we would like that language to be
interpreted the way it's written you
know in the English language um but um
in many past years this has not been a
particular issue but we're in a position
right now some of you will know that
there are people who are rather than
having their benefit deducted from their
um from their retirement check are being
build for it instead um and it's uh it's
under a thousand people but um there's
potential for it to grow and we agree
with Marty that um we should approach
the legislature and come up with that we
have we did ask the Attorney General's
office um Kristen lers who's an
Assistant Attorney General to look at
this issue um a couple years ago and to
do a thorough review and we think the
legislative history is actually there
and is fairly wholsome and um and
reaches a fairly definitive conclusion I
would suggest if you have a subcommittee
look at this that um you should invite
them to testify as well and we would be
happy to work with you on language but
this is a matter of ensuring that the um
State reti Health Plan has sufficient
revenues to support um the current
benefit benefit level which I think is
um a very appropriate benefit level and
is actually a very um wholesome plan for
its
[Music]
members see
none is there anyone else wishing to
speak on
this the chairman it's very difficult to
hear you
Terry can you hear me
now it's much
better okay
um is there anyone else wishing to speak
on this
bill seeing none I will close the
hearing on
[Music]
hb130
all
right thank you and I will now open the
hearing on House Bill
150 and call Representative Shu crie
sponsor thank you madam chair um many of
the members of this committee will
recognize um again Diane Shu marac 20 um
many of the members of this committee
will recognize this bill uh it was
introduced last year by one of our
long-term colleagues The Honorable Mark
PR Mark moved out of his uh old District
during the interim and uh was not I
apparently was not in his new new
District long enough to run for the
house again so I for one hope that uh at
at the next election round we'll see him
back joining us from his new location
anyway um the bill that he introduced
last year House Bill
1377 which was introduced to make a
technical correction to a law enacted in
2019 and was requested by the fish and
game department to make the
clarification uh that language is
exactly what I had drafted into this
bill House Bill
150 that bill 1377 was adopted by this
committee
unanimously passed the house on consent
calendar but then got lost in the
shuffle due to the
pandemic since representative PR was
unable ble to present it this term I'm
hoping I tried to reach out to invite
him to attend today hoping that he might
be willing to testify and explain his
reasons for putting the original bill
in thank you representative Shu uh no
one else has asked to speak on this
bill so anyone if any person does wish
to testify please raise your hand and I
will recognize
you representative
Pearson thank you madam
chairman uh this is
um this is another
bill that ol screwed up the people on
but that's here no there so if for those
that are new to the committee we looked
at this last last
session and one of the reasons for this
really had to do with a
technical mistake or Omission if you
will
um in the sense that you it was it was
including folks you know police officers
firefighters Rescue Squad folks in a
certain area and then not necessarily in
the other area the other issue with this
is if you look down at part
two subparagraph
H it the the original language put a
restriction
into the activities of a rescue squad
member that require them to be involved
in a fish and game activity
to recover a lost person that the reason
why this legislation takes out to
recover a lost person is because that
was so narrowly
defined um you know that it it just it
made the it made the intent of the
legislation have to meet just such a
bizarre requirement and that was you
know that was the big thing that
representative PR was trying to fix so
so you know this isn't really this isn't
inventing something
new it's really just a housekeeping
measure and if you look at the language
in part
C and again the the removal of of 2 that
part at the bottom about having to
recover a lost person it really does put
this back in line with what the original
intent of the legislation
was dare to say that the language
currently requires them to
have for a lost person rather than for
an injured person who location is
now that was correct Madam chairperson
that was that was very much discussed in
length at the you know two years ago or
a year and a half ago whatever when we
had discussed this and you know it was
it was not a big deal then when you know
when we when representative P had
brought this forward it was it was
really just a technical correction
so I mean that's that's what I remember
about his testimony and you know just
looking through the bill itself it's
that's really all it is it's it's not uh
there's really nothing more to than that
so thank
you are there any other people who wish
to testify I don't see any
hands all right then thank you very
much I will close the hearing on House
Bill 150
and it looks like we have some time
before the next
hearing
yes I will open an executive
session does some and would someone have
a motion on either House Bill 150
or House Bill
619 I'd make one on 150 okay um
ought to
pass
second so representative leus has moov
ought to pass representative Roy has
seconded is there any
discussion repres representative
Schulz short caucus with um my fellow
Democrats I'm sorry would you you speak
louder could I request a short
Democratic caucus for our
committee you may I don't know how you
will arrange
it I just know that I had a few
questions on one bill in particular that
I wanted to talk to my fellow Democrats
about and while I don't necessarily mind
a quick exec session I really don't um
okay ready
are the only two bills I think we are
clearly ready to exact are this one
house bill
150 and House Bill 619 where the sponsor
asked us to retain it I would you would
you mind giving me five minutes to call
my ranking member
then did can you hear me yes I heard you
I'm just
uh yes we will
uh we'll take a a short break and
discuss the casually discuss these bills
while
we're give you five minutes thank you
madam
chair so I did manage to uh introduce
the bill and the other one I think they
may have been afraid I was joining
criminal justice Jeff I'm interrupting
Chris um representative
sh mute
yourself they uh they were running late
and then their whole
system uh collapsed we just had the
problem oh there you
go she's not bribing me for my
goat well I don't know she's not that
cheap
that didn't look good I would just
remind everybody in the room that the
the sound is on the system is not muted
for for the committee room nobody has
said anything but I just wanted to say
that
before anybody
does very transparent
about
Pam yes Pam yes uh is Peter um so I know
it's possible to have caucuses through
Zoom because we did it in straford
County but when we had our organizing
meeting but you have to have a
technician uh who knows how to do it uh
and I don't know whether that would mean
you um I I know it would it would not
mean me yeah we're we're not at all
involved in caucuses well but somebody
has to be the technician that sets up
the caucus I'm not sure how how that
would be done whether I've
been somebody's going to reach out to me
or
whatever but U anyway so you're not
involved in that no I'm never involved
in
caucuses right but but somebody has to
be the Techni the host that switches
that sets it up and you are that person
so anyway uh I'll just wait to be
contacted and we how much how much time
did Carol give us
um there was a request for five minutes
five minutes okay good I'll just wait to
be called thank
you I'm I'm sorry I um I could hear
somebody asked to be promoted to co-host
but I couldn't hear who it was that was
representative Roy oh I'm sorry okay
absolutely we
um we lost internet is what happened at
at at know time it just happened that
you were at lunch so you you missed the
excitement but that's why people may
have lost their uh status and we're
happy to be back on you know on track
sorry madam chair I'm finished with that
quick conversation I apologize I wasn't
trying to be difficult and I hope uh I
didn't create a difficulty I just wanted
to make sure I really understood what
was happening and I do now uh no problem
this is our first meeting so we haven't
worked a lot of things out I will say
that we are on a relatively tight
schedule we're going to have to work Zex
in so I would recommend you
caucus as you see F the Republicans had
a caucus last
Thursday and Madam chair I've always
appreciated how efficiently and swiftly
you run the commit so I do I appreciate
that reminder thank
you uh I approve of
[Laughter]
sing all right so resuming our executive
session we have a motion by
representative leus to pass House Bill
150 is there any further
discussion I'll just say that uh as was
said the first part of it is a technical
correction in the first part it includes
uh emergency medical technician Rescue
Squad members and in the second part
which seems to deal with the same thing
just a little variation they left it out
for some reason and in the second one
um you know it's if if people are part
of a um search and rescue effort then I
mean that should cover it and adding to
recover lost person seems pointless
anyway
so I see it as a technical correction we
should just uh
approve
representa Roy I don't see a fiscal note
on this butar would
have
imp maybe maybe not I if I could um I
think on the second part you know
I I don't think that there's probably uh
anybody that's you know part of search
and rescue and then they decide wasn't
involved cou lost person I you know I
don't know that there'd be any there
[Music]
and the first part I don't know how
they've been handling it but
um I think it would be pretty minimal if
any fiscal impact but that's just my
guess
basically yes there aren't that many
debt benefits issued and I would at any
time and I would suspect that in this
case um
and and the only difference would be for
someone an an EMT a rescue squad member
who died and had no surviving dependent
child I mean what you know can happen
but it's it really cuts it down I
think Madam chair I'll point out there
was no fiscal note on the original Bill
1377 either so I think it's been
determined in both session years that U
there is no major fiscal impact to be
considered
Excell oh thank
God thank you sweetie
pie I only have two bills
left you're unmuted
Jackie yes there are two bills left so
that's
correct any other discussion on House
Bill
none the uh clerk will call the
RO representative Roy
yes the clerk votes
yes um representative Pearson
yes representative
yakovich
yes representative leus
yes representative Allegro yes
representative
Bailey representative Bailey yes yes
okay didn't hear you the first time I
had trouble with my
mute representative
lanzara
yes representative Santo
naso
yes representative
goalie yes
yes representative sh
definitely representative Judy
we representative Schmidt
yes representative
Schulz yes representative fellows yes
representative
funno
yes representative groda yes please
representative O'Brien yes and the chair
yes 19 to
nothing we here EXC thank you
excellent uh consent
calendar does anyone object to
consent good we'll put it
on thank you
all uh one one point I have been
instructed that we are not to allow
votes by people who call
in without
video it's not going to matter in this
case but representative Judy does not
appear to have
video um I didn't I believe
representative fno has
video
voice was it voice well yes I'm not
worried about it and in this
bill certainly isn't going to matter
whether it's 18 to Z or 17 to Z but um
in some cases it may make a difference
and I would hope that representative
Judy manag to get
some I I would point out Madam chair
that representative Judy's voice is
probably the most identifiable of all
our committee members so there's no
doubt that's who it is I
agree but we don't know if there's
somebody standing
behind one of Madame Madame chair excuse
me Madame chair I am alone in the house
my wife she's
hospitalized I am aone in the house I I
understand I agree
it just that I think I wanted to point
this rule out and I hope we can manage
to get you
some Madam
chair
yes I just want to pass along uh
representative PR says thank you to the
committee for the vote on this
Bill yes we appreciate
it jerem ask a question yes so what's
the decision is it going to be 18 to
nothing or 17 to nothing
it should be 17 I will discuss this
issue with the speaker but for now
representative
Judy doesn't count so you to
change
yes I think everybody else somebody had
what looked like just a static
image that was
Jackie everyone else seems to have video
I'm right here you can't see
me
um no would that not make the vote 18
nothing I thought it was 19 to nothing
counting him I thought it was 19 to
nothing as
well we can see you Jackie thank you
while everyone's Counting please accept
my apology when I screamed thank God it
was because my husband brought me a cup
of coffee and I didn't realize I was
unmuted I
I've been in my in my office since N9
o'clock apologies
please so M Madam
chair um if you're going to get a
clarification about what to do when the
person can't isn't using Zoom is only
using the telephone could you just
clarify also if video means you have to
see our face or we're just using Zoom
because that's two different
things I think it means you need to use
use your face and in fact I don't
haven't seen representative saso face
today you we we saw him before we saw
him before when he was in his
car oh that's right
yeah all right I'm sorry madam chair
guess I'm going to be that we can't see
you at all all just for whatever it's
worth um I obviously you're in the L but
for what it's worth I can't see anyone
who's actually in the L Edna room or
whatever just for the record well
actually we're down on the second floor
it's not our own room but uh there are
in fact four other members of the
committee who are here and we can all
see each
other great we can see you're visible I
can see yes that's correct you are VIs
visble you're very tiny
but representative Schulz they're in the
long shot technically
speaking yes that's
correct the main screen we should call
it forward that we proceed according to
the rules and if the person cannot be
seen live it's bad enough that we're
doing this in the fashion we forced to
but if a person cannot be seen
live
I I agree and again today I expect the
vote on the next bill to be unanimous
also so I'm not going to worry about it
but I I will get clarification before
our next
Mee Madame chair this is representative
groa if I may I would recommend that
when taking the vote everyone who has is
calling from remote does have their
space visible so that we can at least
see everyone voting in
person and those people on the phone I
do agree I do agree that the rules are
those people calling in on the phone
that are not
visible are not allowed to vote that was
what I read in the um information sent
to
us yes that was I had and I I will get a
clarification I will see what we can do
about representative
Duty
yeah I'd like to point out that hand
hold a representative uh Madam Madame
chair Madam chair this J
Judy uh in that note I see number one to
with uh the B
hhvs and all
tone for higher quality so I don't know
why they put uh all
telephone I'm sorry sorry I didn't
understand you would you repeat that no
I see in my in my calendar we put uh
number one to join the webinar
https and second or
telephone right right but you we
shouldn't be using the calendar Zoom
link we should be using the link that is
sent to us in individually the calendar
link is for the public to to participate
in the meeting of course they don't have
a vote anyway um but uh but it's been
correctly stated that the rule is quite
clear you know if you're on the zoom you
can vote if you're just calling in by
telephone you can't vote uh so maybe
some additional clarification is
possible but that seems fairly
straightforward and and uh we just have
to get you some
technical um improvements so that you
can be on the zoom with the rest of us
but you shouldn't be using the link
that's in the
calendar represent Schmid is exactly
correct you you have been each of us has
been sent twice in fact a link to the
meeting that is unique to
ourselves calendar members of the
public all right
representative Judy do you have a
camera yes I have okay all right on your
phone yes I have okay we'll have to send
somebody to help you figure out how to
how
to L
video all right thank you
um we have five minutes do does someone
have a motion on House Bill
619 represent Representative groda makes
a motion to retain the
bill represent
Roy count
second yes I
can
and and Roy is there any
discussion I can't I can't hear what
that comment was comment was since the
prime sponsor thought the bill needed
some search and has asked us to retain
it
to any other questions I I mean we it's
our bill now we have control over it we
don't have to abide by the prime
sponsors wishes but uh to the degree
that the bill is uh defective or has
issues I think we we should uh you know
we should oblige him and
uh proceed on that basis
I'll support to retain
[Music]
motion thank you madam chair while I am
not in support of uh the bill as written
um I will give the sponsor time to come
back to us uh as he has requested and I
will support the
retain thank you any other
comments in that case clerk will call
the RO to retain to retain
representative Roy
yes votes yes representative Pearson
yes representative
yakovich
yes representative leus yes
representative algro
yes representative
Bailey yes representative Lara
yes representative Santo
naso
yes representative
goalie
sh
yes nice day is it representative Judy
uh pet represent uh
we uh I believe I was called so I voting
yes representative
Schultz yes representative fellows yes
representative
fno yes representative H groa yes
O'Brien yes and the
chair
yes
18 one pH nothing
all right thank you
that's two down 85 to go only 51 to go
all right thank you all and
uh close the executive
session
and open the hearing on House Bill
173 shu to speak
thank you madam chair um again it's
Diane Shu marac 20 here to bother you
again uh introducing House Bill
173 which requires the independent
investment Committee of the retirement
system to report investment
fees this bill is an attempt to add some
transparency to the actions of the
independent investment Committee of the
retirement
system like me I'm sure many of you have
some
Investments uh that you have on the
outside um and it's pretty darger that
you get uh at least quarterly statements
from those investment companies or from
your financial advisor telling you what
they've invested in and what the fees
that they've charged to administer those
Investments are
uh we as employees and I'm a retired
state employee I'll state that out there
and as
employers uh which the state budget uh
pays for state employees portion of
retirement uh I feel we should have the
right to
know exactly how the fees that are being
paid how much the fees are to what kinds
of Investments
counselors or advisers are being used uh
right now all that we get is the lumpsum
figure this much has been spent and then
we get the returns and quite a few of us
were quite alarmed at the returns at the
end of the fiscal year in June of uh
2020 when they came back with a return
of
1.1% uh it seemed quite
um low and basically abnormal compared
to many other and many other funds that
are out
there so this is just an attempt as I
said to try and have these figures be
made public uh I understand that Mr
Carlin has said that they can be posted
on the retirement website uh the cost
should not be anything major it's I I
honestly believe that these figures are
probably reported to the investment
committee and it's just a matter of
relinquishing them to the membership and
the
employers thank you are there
questions see
none yes I'd like to point out a couple
of things uh first uh the
there is no connection between the fees
that we pay and the return that we get
I'm not opposed to the bill but I don't
see how knowing that the ABC manager uh
voted this way or that way how that
actually will affect us the other thing
is uh yes we Pro we may be under this
time but nobody ever says anything when
it hits 14% so it's uh we we can't be
Monday morning quarterbacks I'm voting
for the
bill I I if taking that as perhaps a
question um I will say that I think if
the fees that are paid to as I said
specific uh Consultants or firms uh
would give a better judge of the value
of the judgments that are being made and
I think if
the Judgment of one or more members or
the entire investment committee are in
question that's probably the only way
that we could
tell thank you representative fellows
you had a
question yes thank you madam chair um uh
representative Shu do you know if other
state
employee retirement funds have a report
like that that they make
available yes I understand that there
are many I don't have the exact number
uh I'm guessing probably Mr Carlin could
tell us he's the next
speaker see no other questions thank you
representa thank
you recognize Marty Carlin from the
retirement
thank you madam chair again for the
record uh my name is Marty Carlin
representing
nhrs um this this bill was uh put in
last year and made it through the house
and died in another Omnibus Bill over
the summer uh at that time just like now
um you know we have no position on the
bill and believe we would be able to
produce a quarterly report um you know
without any additional uh significant
expense um just to address a couple of
the the um comments made earlier just by
way of background um I did want to say
that um you
know National Council on Public Employee
Retirement Systems NC Pur does a survey
of participants on investment fees and
our our fees were lower than the
national average by a fairly significant
margin in the last survey as a
percentage of assets it was 30 basis
points or. 3% of assets and the national
average was 48 BAS
points um additionally um we do um in
with new manager agreements we have what
we refer to as a most favored nation
clause uh in investment agreements which
says that if another comparable public
plan invests at the fund with a lower
fee structure and that we currently have
our fees will be um adjusted downward so
I I just wanted to reassure that the
committee uh this committee Edna that
the investment committee does all its
can all it C all it can do to try to
manage fees and keep them uh at a
reasonable level um in terms of
transparency just if if you're not aware
uh the investment committee does meet
monthly and and those meetings are open
to the public uh they seldom if ever go
into non-public session um so folks can
can observe uh if they would like and uh
since last year another member has been
added to the investment committee by
Statute a an existing Public Employee
member a Portsmouth fire captain so
there's uh someone from the membership
who's you know involved in the committee
and and following all this um with that
again we have no position or or concern
with the bill so I'll yeld the floor and
welcome any questions if you have
any thank you are there
questions representative
Shu thank you madam chair um Mr Carlin
um I is it not true that the employee
member uh was put in as a nonvoting
member that that's correct the
legislation added um the the member is a
non- voting member although um he still
is you know full contributor and asks
questions and sees all the same material
it's it with with that addition it's a
six- member committee there's five
voting members and the Public Employee
thank you representa fellows yes thank
you madam chair um can you just answer
the question question that I asked
representative she would about do other
states um produce a similar report in
for their Retirement Systems um you know
what you're going to see uh n nationally
is probably a hodg Podge I'm I'm sure
some do um and and some some may not um
that's one thing with investment fees
that actually the the gby governmental
governmental Accounting Standards Board
is looking at in terms of uh
establishing National
standards on fee reporting they kicked
off a gasby project on that last year
and they're looking into sort of
standardizing that and to get a clean
audit opinion you need to um follow the
gasby standards so whatever they come
out with you know if if it's not what
we're already doing we would adjust
accordingly but you know there's it
varies quite a bit from state to state I
I I can't point to any state that has a
you know a goal standard you know report
um type of thing but but different
levels of disclosure know around the
country so that after this bill is
implemented New Hampshire will be the
cold
standard depends on who's weighing the
gold all right any other
questions all
right Richard
gulla uh can everyone hear me yes great
um thank you uh for having me today my
name is Richard gulla I am am president
of the state employees Association SEIU
Local 1984 uh represent nearly 10,000
employees here at the State of New
Hampshire County Municipal uh I'll be
brief um House Bill 173 is asking for
not only the disclosure of the amounts
of the investment fees but is also a
transcription of the fees this brings
further transparency and accountability
to the investment process this will help
provide an opportunity for the members
both active and tired of the system as
well as the public at large to ensure
that the fees being paid to invest A9
billion Public Employee Retirement plan
are being spent wisely like many other
factors investment fees are an important
piece of keeping the retirement solvent
and stable uh we are concerned with
seeing only a 1.1% return for fiscal
year 2020 um where many other states
outperform New Hampshire
significantly um
and House Bill 173 will allow for
transparency and accountability in the
investment process to ensure that the
funds used to provide benefits are being
protected and also being done in a
prudent manner manner to provide stable
and predictable rates for our employees
and retirees and uh with that I will
conclude my testimony and thank
you
see none is there anyone else who
wish having trouble hearing you
again
yesy
13 chair this this is not an issue of
your microphone the members need to mute
there everybody's got to be on mute
otherwise we're not going to hear the
primary
microphone I'm sorry piar I didn't hear
you sorry my microphone wasn't turned on
that was
operator I I repeat is there anyone else
who wishes to speak on House Bill
seeing none I'm going to close the
hearing and since we have a few minutes
go into executive session on House Bill
173 and I recognize representative Roy
for a
motion is there a second second second I
couldn't hear them okay we're goalie
seconds is there any would you care to
speak on
um I
think
State
goie I was having a hard time hearing
representative Roy Madam
chair so was I I couldn't actually hear
the motion that he
made second
that microphone on the floor yes sorry
we're having trouble yes representative
Roy is speaking with a flight inside
voice and it's not transmitting very
well microphone
desk okay hello
I that's that's
better
y CH I got to leave the meeting I'm
out okay
see you Steve in any event the motion is
ought to pass by representative Roy
seconded by representative
bie followed by technical issues are
there is there any discussion of the
motion representative CIT um this is
getting I'll Vote for This of course but
it's getting into the weeds I don't know
how how many managers there are how they
build how they're tied to specific funds
I I don't know how this really does
does it's great but I don't see how it's
going to accomplish anything unless you
are really in into this whole I'll call
it the weeds of the pro the details of
how this is all done it's all a mystery
to me so I'll leave it at
that is there anyone
else all right seeing none motion is
ought to pass and the clerk will call
the all representative Roy yes the clerk
yes representative
Pearson he has left the
meeting what happened to
him he not
voting representative
yakovich
[Music]
yes
yes representative
Bailey yes representative
Laro
yes representative Sant
naso
yes representative
goie
yes representative show it yes represent
Dy is here representative
Schmid
yes
representative
Schultz yes representative fellows yes
representative fno yes representative
Broda yes representative O'Brien
yes and representative Ru the chair
yes uh looks like it's going to be
17 does anyone object to
consent seeing none we'll put that one
on
consent um can I just hear what the
count was 17 to
zero since representative Schmidt left
the
meeting representative Pearson left the
meeting excuse me
usually tell
them we
have 12 minutes before the next bill if
does anyone think there is another bill
that we could exec in that period of
time
possibly
130 possibly
130 possibly I think the 130 has a
problem that
the right uh
representative Roy suggest that we
address House Bill
91 if we
complete not we
will
adjourn recess the executive session
until
later I move um 91 off the
pass repeat that
pleas House Bill 91 no
to
passid
second you wish to speak to your your
your motion I could have a
microphone thank you uh I had moved off
the pass on this I believe that this
legislation is um is keeping in line
with with the um sentiment in the idea
of line of duty deaths I believe that
there was ample
testimony that given the new awareness
of PTSD and the effect on emergency
workers that this should um definitely
be
considered
covered like I said I think we all heard
the testimony I
thought I
move
pres Schmid you to say
something I do Madam
chair let me just get myself
up so uh I think we heard the same test
last time and approved the bill one
thing that was new this time was the
statement that research shows that um
that such a provision does not in fact
uh lead uh to SU suicide
ideation um and we recognize of course
uh not too many people are going to kill
themselves for others benefit but the
benefit is for the family and the
survivors um and I I fully support the
idea that uh we need to do something
about this uh and for the for our First
Responders who are under tremendous
stress in their chosen profession so
I'll happily
vote for the bill as
well second yes okay sorry
I'm is there any other representative Al
yes um I'm concerned that this bill
changes the mean meaning of the words in
the line of
duty um and not withstanding the
testimony that we've heard that
suggested that $100,000 is not an
inducement
um $100,000 is a chunk of
change and as I heard it said to me
recently um
just you know by way of example you have
a uh a police officer who is stressed on
the job stressed financially stressed
for personal
reasons and he's looking at the
possibility of gaining $100,000 for his
family um I'm concerned that it it
brings into effect the Geor valy uh path
which is I'm worth more dead than alive
to my family also uh again not
withstanding the testimony that we heard
which I do not believe is supported by
um any evidence the bill is a reward for
and an inducement to commit suicide it's
a step towards the acceptance and
normalization of
suicide um rather than to support those
who are considering suicide so I cannot
bring myself to support this
legislation I don't have all that much
history but when there's been an
unfortunate event with the state
employee not covered there have been I
don't think I'm wrong on this specific
bills brought in to help the Widow help
the family
and uh
I think that would probably happen in
such a circumstance and I would prefer
to see it as policy rather than somebody
coming uh to the legislature
for an unfortunate event this is a tough
one I don't think we're
gonna I guess your principle is right
but it's just not going to be a lot of
this
so I I'll vote
for
goalie thank you madam
chair this bill passed committee 18
to1 uh last
year and I'm going to support this um
and coming from a personal experience I
retired uh most of you know in November
uh my last day working me just a fire I
spent at a funeral for a coworker who
had committed
suicide uh who worked with me at
justifier um I wish we would have passed
it last year so his family
uh eled on this benefit unfortunately
we're a year too late for them but I
don't want to see it happen to anyone
else um so I will support
this um thank you madam chair um my
concern is not with the concept that
that I'm fine with that it I'm just
concerned with that sentence that was a
committee addition to this bill last
time around the one that says death by
Suicide should be considered a work
[Music]
related cause of death and it it just
seems to me that in many cases it is but
it it might not always be um it could be
that the the person you know just had
some you know personal issues or home
issues you know somebody who just uh was
sered divorce papers or something like
that so that the cause could be
something that's not work rated and my
recollection which is fuzzy is that last
year there was somebody
testified that that that wouldn't
be that that that that would not cause
this benefit
to um be delivered if it was clearly not
a
work-related uh event that caused the
suicide but I I'm not nobody testified
to that this time and so that leaves me
up in the air you know I except I like
the concept I'm just concerned about the
wording that particular
sentence you representative O'Brien
uh thank you madam chair I would just
like to say that uh I am going to
support this uh and I want you all if I
may share with you I think we're just
really uh scratching the tip of the
iceberg on this this is been a long time
to come to address this particular issue
uh you got to keep in mind uh like you
say something that may not be related to
the job but everything is
cumulative uh there are our events you
paid me as a firefighter I held the rank
of deputy chief for the city of nashille
for 15 years I've worked many many times
uh suggested many many times to some of
my uh uh co-workers uh that they go into
EAP you don't know what they deal with
uh you may say oh something's going
wrong with the marriage but many times I
have seen some of the problems within
the marriage has been dragged home from
the fir house it is an occupation where
you pay us to man that wall and we do it
so you can sit home in your armchairs
and the key is this we see things that
you should not see it's terrible enough
that we see them and for a culture of
the fire department I'm sure with the
police uh there's been many many years
where the answer was going out with your
buddies and the answer is in the bottom
of the bottle thank God that has changed
and now with the highlight and with uh
Progressive uh legislation such as this
this has got to go a long way again it's
scratching the tip of the iceberg but it
is a reality uh every firefighter knows
another firefighter who has committed
suicide many firefighter knows another
firefighter that is said what if if I
reached out another two feet could I
grab that kid I'm not trying to be
melodramatic but every firefighter does
know what do you think the victims of a
car accident when they hit a tree they
remain quiet they're not screaming
they're not calling for Mama and trying
to get you out of while you're trying to
extricate them these are horrific things
and and it again you got to keep in mind
it's cumulative it adds up and uh so
therefore something like this will do
have happen but this is not the Panacea
we got to try to stop it on the other
end from occurring but recognizing when
a suicide does occur we are sympathetic
to come up with the benefits thank you
thank you uh representative Schulz you
have two minutes and then we will
adjourn the executive session thank you
madam chair um I'm tempted to talk about
how offended I am by a previous uh
colleagues remarks but I'll just Express
gratitude to those of you who have uh
seemed to get that the brain is an organ
in the body and that the stigma around
mental illness must stop especially when
we have plenty of research that the
folks who are put in extreme extremely
stressful and traumatic uh
jobs uh serving for us um that they
would have have uh repercussions from
that in their brain and their body is
not a shock we have plenty of research
to show that and I just want to say I'm
I'm very proud that the majority of us
seem to get that uh it's time to end the
stigma around mental
illness thank you uh thank you thank you
for
being
[Music]
I just wanted to address representative
fellow's question real quick if you look
at line F on um on the bill it talks
about because you were concerned about
what's considered a duty cause of death
it it specifically says his or her
duties as a result of an incident
accident or violence causing death or
injuries which are direct or approximate
cause of death so in order to award the
benefits you know there'd have to be
some kind of tieback to the job so as
far as you know someone can make suicide
that has nothing to do with their job
there would be an investigation before
it was
important okay thank you uh we're
obviously not ready to vote so I will
adjourn the executive session to be
resumed at a later point
and open the public hearing on House
Bill 39
representative O'Brien you're the prime
sponsor would you care to introduce
it thank you uh Madam
chair uh I good to see everybody back on
the committee and uh I would like to
introduce House Bill
390 this is another attempt of mine and
where with encouragement from my
municipality but this is not really just
to help the nation taxpayers it is the
hope that we can help all of the
taxpayers in the state to step back and
remember the conversations that we
shared on House Bill
274 we have stated that there was a
problem when the state went from the 3
5%
contributions down to
nothing well what had happened in the
meantime since
that the New Hampshire State retirement
system came up and wanted to get rid of
all the unfunded
liability
now they came up and if you remember
somewhat and Mr Colin will probably
correct me if I'm wrong but I did maybe
get the
impression that they came up with
something like 30 years they could have
probably came up with 50 years but what
I do know in people that probably go out
at home and they go out and they get
like a 15-year morgage on their house
and then to come find out that some uh
personal tragedies or some other more
pressing Financial
Obligations uh do come up people
sometimes do go up and they renegotiate
the
loans now you can say that's kicking the
can down the
road maybe this is kicking the can down
the road but what the problem is the
current state of payment that
municipalities have to pay right now is
hurting them right now we have covid
CO's not going away probably for the
next couple years a lot of money has
been invested Ed into the individual
communities uh communities in the
example such as nashwa has gone out of
its way to try to help our our
businesses similar to Manchester and I
think Manchester got the idea from us
but I'll just be proud of my
municipality but the thing is uh of
having outside dining well Nash has lost
some of the parking revenue from some of
that but all these little chinks in the
armas is coming up and trying to get to
the uh take care of the unfunded
liability now if you remember in part of
the presentation that the New Hampshire
retirement system did give us there is
no guarantee in 2039 that all unfunded
liabilities will be paid
for so it is the hope of considering
this that
municipalities may be able to make the
choice to whether to pay this up front
let's say like
payment or maybe to ask to renegotiate
to which this bill would be doing and
coming up extenda extenuating it an
additional four years uh to uh five
years excuse me to
2044 now yes will it be expensive
municipalities will probably pay more in
the uh interest in doing this but will
it get them out of the immediate trouble
right now and it's something to consider
between this
bill uh
390 and if I may briefly Madam chair
with Indulgence I mentioned 274
again one of these got to go through to
help about our cities and towns deal
with the pension costs uh like the
national mayor has
stated uh all you need is $2 million
to raise the tax rate
1% and uh that has already happened in
Manchester it has happened in as and
it's happened in each and every single
one of your communities if you have
teachers firefighters police officers
that are in the nhrs pension system so
Madam chair I'm not going to get too
deep into the weeds again we do have the
mayor of the city of nashal I hope is on
that could come up and speak and through
your Indulgence at the end because he
did not sound uh sign up but also
willing to wanting to speak will be John
Griffin CFO of uh the city of Nash so uh
Madame chair I can conclude my opening
remarks thank you are there questions
from the
committee
thank you very much thank you madam
chair well Marty
Carlin thank you Madame chair um uh
executive director George Legos will be
joining me we're going to co- testify if
U if possible he also signed up um for
to to testify and you can while you're
letting him and I can get started um we
did provide a handout um on HB 390 uh
through Pam to the committee I'm not
going to read the entire handout but I
do have some um comments to make before
turning it over to George and then both
of us would be glad to um collaborate to
answer any questions you may have about
um any of our testimony um as as stated
House Bill uh 390 would extend the
amortization period of the unfunded
liability as of June 30th of 2017 which
is about five billion of the six six
billion total liability uh from its
current 30-year period ending in 2039
for another five years through
2044 um at its um January 12th 2021
meeting our Board of Trustees voted 110
to oppose the bill as counter to the
board's fiduciary duty of prudence and
requirement to adhere to sound Actuarial
practice uh the opposition is similar uh
to uh a 2017 bill which representative
O'Brien referred to which would have
extended the amortization uh by 10 years
um that bill was ultimately voted in
expedient to legislate um by the house
now this is not to say that nhrs doesn't
truly understand and sympathize with the
challenges our participating employers
are currently facing and any and all
efforts they are making to reduce the
local uh tax burden uh however um there
is very limited discretion in setting
employer contribution rates the state
constitution state law and as as
mentioned mention by U another person
who spoke this morning fiduciary duty
required the board to um use sound actal
standards and setting employer
contribution rates necessary to keep the
retirement system on track now among the
factors that the board considered uh in
its decision to oppose this bill which
is fairly rare you tend to hear me say
we have no position on anything um but
the board does uh when it gets to a
fiduciary level occasionally take a
position on a bill uh among the concerns
were that HB 390 defers a significant
portion of the unfunded liability
payment into the 2040s increasing the
ultimate cost that employers will pay um
by approximately 1.4 billion um another
way to look at that is for every dollar
that is not paid between next year and
2039 uh the communities will be paying
$2 back um between 2040 and
2044 um
and as again alluded to uh prior um you
know some some issues back in the 90s
and it was actually exactly 30 years ago
back in 1991 uh when there was going to
be a significant percentage increase uh
to the 1992 93 employer contribution
rates the rates were much lower than but
in terms of a percentage increase that
that increase was going to be actually
higher than the 20% we've seen in
2022 um and legislation um you know this
this was occurring in a recession uh
there was a a real estate bubble that
had burst and there was banking crisis
in the state um you know and there were
a lot of pressures on local communities
in terms of cost so legislation was
introduced that was pitched as a
temporary attempt to mitigate the
employer contribution increase by
changing the Actuarial method by which
our funding was calculated that's not
what this bill does it's it IT addresses
it in a different way um but the
temporary solution that was adopted by
the legislature back in
1991 remained in the law until 2007 uh
and it contributed significantly to the
current unfunded pension liability
essentially the folks taxpayers myself
included um are paying for decisions
made 30 years ago now
um and so to repeat um you know that
attempt is is going to lead to a similar
con conversation in this chamber uh back
in 2040 or
2039 um additionally uh you know the
board felt that HB 390 would set a
dangerous precedent uh to create a
template to refinance pension
obligations at the expensive future
Generations um back in 2007 the
legislature with input from actuaries
adopted the 30-year amortization plan
that commenced in 2010 30 years was the
uh maximum amount allowed under gasby
standards at the time um it gby has
gotten out of the standard business on
that but um other Accounting Standards
folks refer to a 15 or 20 year
amortization is more ideal but that was
that was what the legislature adopted um
you know this proposal would constitute
a deviation from that plan and a step
backward in terms of the progress we've
made um since recognizing the liability
um as mentioned in our presentation to
the committee earlier month um we've
made positive progress in in um
improving the funded status over the
past decade while many other plans were
moving in the opposite direction uh and
the reason for this is that we have a
funding plan and we're sticking to it um
so I'd like to defer to George Legos for
some additional comments after which um
we'd be glad to answer any
questions Loos you recogniz okay I'm I'm
on with you
yes thank you um thank you madam chair
um well um between our bill brief and
Marty's testimony Marty's covered it
quite well I think he's given you the
landscape um and I just want to
reiterate a couple things without
repeating everything he said first is we
certainly do appreciate the pressure
that's put on um local and school
budgets and we understand the concerns
that have been expressed um one
fundamental thing I just want to say
about the public pension plan is that
you know one of the underlying concepts
of how this best works is when the
liabilities that are created with
somebody's employment for his future
pension or his or her future pension are
are realized um the idea is that they
should be paid for as we go along and
that's when the plan works ideally well
in other words if you do that
successfully every year you never have
an unfunded liability and we'd be paying
the normal cost now and we wouldn't be
having um 80% of the employer
contribution going to to the unfunded
liability however that's the position
we're in as as we all know um and that's
the as a result of not paying the
liabilities as they acred and pushing
them out into the future in order to
solve an immediate problem and
unfortunately that's not that far apart
from where we are right now today
talking about similar things um and that
and that can be very dangerous because
you are pushing the liability out into
the future and it's a precedent you
don't want to follow I think the legis
has done an excellent job uh since the
recognition of these liabilities about
30 years ago when they created the
30-year amortization schedule and made
some other reforms to address these
issues and since that time the
legislature has also been very good
about being consistent and diligent and
sticking with the plan and um members of
the committee that's really the message
I want to reinforce here um you know I
I've I've appeared before the committee
on very rare occasions because uh it's
not often that the board takes a
position and and it and Marty typically
deals with things dayto day but um this
situation is one where there is concern
of the president that's you know that's
how we got in the position we're in and
perpetuating that is a very dangerous
thing I think uh for for not only the
current plan but the plan as it will be
20 or 30 years from now so what's really
uh not what's most important with the
pension plan is is not so much where you
are because our funded status isn't
terrific it's
61% and but it has increased gradually
um over the past 10 years even though
we've changed assumptions a couple of
times which increase the liabilities um
and also have an impact on the funded
ratio but nonetheless we've made some
good progress so what's more important
than where you are is where you're going
and where we're going because of the
plan we have is that the original
unfunded liability that was advertised
for 30 years should in fact be paid off
in
2039 um that's the way it's structured
um future liabilities or or gains that
happen between now and 2039 are going to
be separately amortized and I don't want
to get down into the the Weeds on that
but that there are two different
amortizations going on um so getting
back to the point of um where you're
going is the most important thing where
we're going is we're improving the
funded status and we have a plan to do
that the last thing I'll say just
because I can't resist I think I've said
it anytime I've testified about the
unfunded liability is you know the basic
notion of when you're digging a hole you
can either keep digging stop digging or
fill in the hole and the plan we have
here is to fill in the hole and once we
start extending liabilities out into the
future once again um you know then we
are adding to the Future burden on on
the taxpayers um so with that um I I'm
here on behalf of the board of trust D
to respectfully request that the
committee um does not pass this bill and
declares it um inexpedient to legislate
thank you very much I'm happy to take
any
questions thank you mros
represent sure um as I understand it you
correct me if I'm
wrong um a significant portion of what
the employers are paying is is to is
that amortization and in uh
2039 or after 2039 that will end or
largely end so what I'm asking is about
what portion of what the employers are
paying right now is the amortization
versus what they should be contributing
for pensions for their current employees
and by how much would you expect what
the employers have to pay to drop after
the
2039 amortization periods over if we do
not uh enact
this okay well right right now the uh
roughly speaking about 80% of what the
employers pay uh toward contributions
for their employees is attributable to
the unfunded liability the vast majority
of that is associated with the
amortization of the debt out to
2039 um there's a very I don't want to
get too technical but the the layered
amortization approach just started this
last um valuation period so there's two
years of unfunded liability associated
with that that's going to be amortized
out of 20 so the the the clearest way I
can answer your question is um the
original 30-year amortization schedule
calls for the payment of all of that
amortization of all that unfunded
liability so that should reduce that to
zero what is an unknown is what the
future gains and losses will be between
now and
20139 thank you thank you other
questions I guess
um so if if I'm understanding correctly
80% of uh what the Employers in you know
cities towns the state counties are
paying into the pension fund
80% is H due to that and is it true then
that means that you know
assuming that uh the you know that the
amount that that things are fully funded
going forward and there aren't any
misestimates and all that
that you'd expect after 2039 that that
for you know what they'd be paying would
be would that 80% would basically go
away that that is the way the
amortization schedule should work with
regard to that segment of liability yes
right thank you you're
welcome um thank you madam chair that
may have been the answer to my question
my question was was going to be it's 80%
right now does it decline as we get
closer to the end of the amotization
yes um yes it does and in fact um it's a
30-year anization the first 10 years the
unfunded liability actually uh increased
a little bit because uh of what's called
negative amortization we've now crossed
over so what we should see using those
you know that that statement with regard
to assumptions if there were no further
liabilities Associated or increased um
it would continue to decline over that
period of
time representative fellow the repayment
is based on a fixed percentage of
payroll and so
it isn't exactly the same every year but
it is it will it will
work uh followup basically to that um
it's not sure I understand
so what is it why is it that the payment
that the mun employers will have to make
towards the amortization why will it be
going down over time the mortgage you
know you pay a mortgage as payments are
are fixed it's just how much goes to
principal or interest varies how does
this can take that one George um this is
Marty Carlin um as representative U
Maguire mentioned employer rates are
assessed as a percentage of covered
payroll and that's that's not a mortgage
concept so sometimes when we use the
mortgage analogy Loosely it it doesn't
tie exactly together basically you know
the idea is if all the assumptions were
met you know every single year going
forward through 2039 the percentage of
pay uh on the rate would not change so
if it was you know 14% now for members
you you're paying you're still going to
be paying
14% 10 years from now 15 years from now
on a larger payroll base grown through
inflation um so in terms of actual
dollars year-over-year the contributions
to the retirement system are going to
continue to grow through through
2039 um when the bulk of that initial
unfunded liability as of 630 of 17 is
paid off and then the dollar amount
would would reduce um it still be some
liability the the billion or so that's
been incurred since 2017 uh mainly due
to the Assumption changes and then
anything else that were to happen
positively or negatively over the next
15 to 20 years um so with this bill
you'd see the dollar amount being paid
continue to rise through
2044 um you know at at a higher you know
the the curve would continue to the wave
would just get higher you know in the
total dollar amounts paid in those last
years in the 2040s would be you know the
highest levels ever you know it it just
goes
up other
questions thank you Mr Carlin and Mr
logos I pa Laura teski
tki thank you very much Madam chairman
um my name is representative Laura tersi
and I represent nashua's Ward 8 which is
Hillsboro 35 I'll be very brief um I
know you've had a very long day um but I
did want to take the moment to advocate
for my city of NASA as well as the other
towns and municipalities in the state
that are finding themselves struggling
with this issue uh the the issue is we
need cities and towns need relief now
we're experiencing a once- in a-lifetime
pandemic that came out of nowhere
revenues are up in the air and a life
raft has to be thrown as soon as
possible uh passing this bill or perhaps
uh representative O'Brien's Bill earlier
today is just two possibilities of
something that can be done the reality
is our retirees and our future retirees
are going to be the ones who are
actually hit hardest here their property
taxes are going to go up and they're
going to need to find ways to make ends
meet when they're already struggling uh
this bill simply provides a little more
time to get to that 100% funding I hope
you can support the bill for what it is
which is simply necessary relief for us
to get through this challenging moment
that our cities and towns did not
anticipate and I thank you very much for
your
time are there any
questions see none thank you
representative Paul Arthur
bod thank you madam chairman can you
hear
me you can hear me okay I can hear you
thank you U Madam chairman members of
the committee uh my name is Arthur bodri
I represent the New Hampshire State
permanent firefighters retirement
Association and I'm here today to speak
in opposition of House Bill 390 I would
like to give a the committee a little
background about myself I am a retired
captain from the Manchester fire
department and I was a trustee of the
New Hampshire retirement system Board of
Trustees from 1988 to 2001 anyone who
was around in the 1990s as I was should
remember what took place then and it
seems this legislation will bring the
retirement system uh down the same path
in 1990 uh the legislature decided uh to
change the interest assumption rate from
8% to 9 and 3/4% and change the
methodology from entry age normal to an
open aggregate group method by making
these changes the state and local
Community saved around $72 million
needless to say these changes
contributed greatly to the system
becoming woefully underfunded and these
again it's deja vu because that the
cities and towns were complaining back
then that they didn't want to pay the
normal cost uh I bring this up because
house bills 39 at 390 will bring the New
Hampshire retirement system down the
same path as in
1990 um currently the unfunded acrude
liability uh will be paid off in 20 39
enacting this bill will again push the
liabilities down the road another five
years at an additional cost to the
employers of $1.4 billion dollar yes I
said billion with a B for every dollar
the employer saves today it will cost
them $2 in the future Pennywise dollar
foolish the New Hampshire retirement
system contribution should be based on
sound Actuarial procedures and not based
on uh what the economy is
at this at this P particular time um
hopefully uh we have learned from our
mistakes in the past and please do not
allow history to repeat itself um if you
look I I have some old data I don't know
what the retirement system has given you
uh today but um if you look at once the
unfunded acrude liability is paid off uh
the employer normal cost is going to go
down astronomically I mean the numbers I
have the employees would be uh at uh 1.2
uh 92% teachers will go down to
1.86% police will be at
5.04% and fire will be at
6.35% that is much less than what the uh
employee will be paying and even back in
the 1990s when they chose to change the
methodology and change the interest
assumption rate to save the cities and
towns money the employees at the time I
believe except maybe fire we not but the
employees on uh teachers state employees
and I believe police were paying the
employer employee was paying more into
the retirement system than the employee
so um you know the the unfunded acude
liability has to be paid off and the
longer we keep pushing this off you're
looking at billions of dollars that the
taxpayers are going to have to come up
with in the future so with that said I
would uh please uh appreciate that the
committee vote to itl House Bill 390 and
uh I thank you for your time and I'll
answer any
questions thank you Mr bed other
questions thank you very
much representative
pearon I got a question for Mr B if he's
still
on I am still here if you can hear
me I can
it's my understanding and I may be
confusing the group so this is my
question it's my understanding the the
organization that which you are
president of sounded a very loud alarm
in the 90s warning
communities that the actions that were
being
taken and the funding method that was
being used was inadequate incorrect
in woful negligent was that your
organization that sounded that alarm in
the early 90s or was it somebody else no
it was the permanent firefighters
Association that did that and that was
when I was seated as a trustee um we
warned them back then we even testified
before the legislature that it was
inappropriate for them to take the
authority away from the Board of
Trustees at the time to set the interest
assumption rates and change the
methodology um and uh
it went on deaf ears and it was all
because the cities and towns and the
state wanted to save money at the time
and this is what happens when you try to
save money um it ends up costing you
more in the long run but yes it was the
New Hampshire State permanent
firefighters retirement Association that
was on record then and contined to be on
record for many years after that that
was not the way to
go thank you are there any any other
questions from the
committee see none thank you Mr bodri
thank you Madame chairman mayor
dones yes Madam uh Madam chair can you
hear me
yes um all right well I won't
repeat some of the testimony that I gave
you regarding House Bill 274 concerning
the hardship this is going to cause or
is causing on taxpayers across the state
and representative ters touched on that
as well so I will not repeat that but
instead talk about the tech you know
some of the aspects of this particular
bill now the reason we're here is that
the state retirement system reduced the
assumed rate of return over the next
decades uh by half a percent I believe
Mr Lagos can correct me if I'm wrong but
I think from 675 to 625 or from 725 to
675 but reduced it by by half a percent
now before that decision was made the
the system was 65 or 66% funded uh the
reduction in the assumed rate of return
uh caused is causing this increase uh
over and above what would normally be
caused by uh the increase in you know
natural increase in wages now again I
give you nashal's numbers not because
we're different or more important but
just because it gives I can give you
those those numbers and it gives you a
perspective uh we're we're going to be
going up from about 25 million to nearly
$30 million this year paid into the
state pension
system 80% of which you've heard that
four fifths 80% of which are has nothing
to do with current employees all has to
do with the recapitalization or the
building up of the reserves in the
pension system 84 of the money we're
paying in is for this unfunded liability
or on $30
million that's about $24 million dollar
we paying on an annual basis under the
unless you know you you help us with
this bill $24 million into the unfunded
liability this is nowhere near 1991 this
is a totally different
situation in
1991 decisions were made when the when
the fund was 100% which were not sound
yes I mean everybody agrees on
that uh which resulted in part in the
underfunding that we have faced you know
in the last 10 or 15
years but right now again we are paying
five times under the you know without
some relief five times what it takes to
support current
employees with this uh with this
increase in other
words 80% of what we're paying is for
the unfunded liability so we're paying
five times what it takes to meet uh the
obligations that will be created for
current employees back in 19
1991 they made a decision which caused
the contributions coming in to be less
than were necessary even to pay for the
current retirees that is not what we're
advocating at all we're currently paying
five times what it takes for or we would
be paying five times what it takes to
support current
retirees now if you give us this
fiveyear relief it will ballpark I mean
you could get these specific numbers but
ballpark it would about offset the the
in our case again just using our numbers
the $4 million increase that was caused
by the reduction in the assumed rate of
return so think about that all right so
then we're paying in 25 26
million instead of 29 or
30 still it's only going to take you
know 20% of the 30 million it's only
going to take about 6 million dollar to
fund any obligations that would be
incurred as a result of current
employees so if you give us this relief
and our contribution is 25 instead of 30
or whatever in we will still be
paying 18 19 20 million towards the
unfunded liability so the idea that we
would be digging a hole no we would
still be paying millions and millions
and millions of dollars every year to
help fund help fill this you know help
uh build up the reserves so the idea
that we would be digging a hole or this
is like 1991 it has there's no
comparison no similarity at
all I wanted to address the issue of you
know this will cause cost more money in
the
future it's and the home mortgage is you
know an approximate
analogy if I the cheapest way to buy a
house is you know in terms of total
dollars out is simply to pay cash just
go across the street put down three
00,000 and you got the house you don't
have to pay any interest no future cost
no
problem people can't afford to do
that the next cheapest way is like a
five or a 10e
mortgage less interest than a 30 a lot
less you pay less over time but people
can't afford that they don't have enough
money in the
present you can you know 15-year
mortgages are available most people
don't do that because they don't have
the money so they they the standard is a
30-year
mortgage um so the IDE so the idea that
you know it is somehow illegitimate to
say look we just we we uh instead of
paying this back
over um 23 years we need a little bit
extra
time or excuse me instead of paying it
over 18 years we need a little extra
time that's not so unusual we're still
paying it off we're still principal
payments every month just not quite as
much and the reason we're asking is we
can't afford this right now Co and
everything else uh this is you know
about 15% of the taxes that a taxpayer
pays in are for this one line
item uh that's for an average homeowner
it's almost ,000 they're paying in just
on this one
thing so uh it's not so unusual for us
to ask for a little time and just to get
into a little more Deep In The Weeds
Madam chair yes in 2043 you know a
dollar there would be extra interest
paid but if you use sort of a
financial methodology money paid out in
the future does not have you know has a
has Le a dollar paid in 19 years does
not have a present value of a dollar it
it has the present value of you know you
can figure it out depending on the
assumed rate of interest but might be 50
cents so you know in present day dollars
you're really not paying out more
money uh yes you're paying dollars that
are worth less than a dollar today way
in the future but that's pretty
Technical and then the weeds so I just
go back to the point is we we need
relief we would still be paying tens of
millions of dollars to P to uh settle
the unfunded liability and giving us a
little relief a little little extra time
is not going to be the end of the world
finally Madam chair I apologize but I
wanted to make this point I'll try to
make it
briefly the idea that F the pension
systems have to be at 100% make more
sense in the private
sector if GM goes bankrupt and if they
if they punch if their pension system is
not 100%
funded
the the pensioners don't get
paid because they they get partially
paid but mostly
not but that is if GM ends and goes
bankrupt now we are a state part of the
United
States the only way that this pension
system and the state of New Hampshire
will stop and there would be a necessity
to just have in the bank enough to pay
out everything without any more
contributions would be if the state
ceased to exist as an entity because
otherwise there there's 10 billion in
the bank you're getting contributions
every year which greatly exceed the need
for current retirees so unless the state
ceases as an entity whether you're at 60
or 80 or 85 or whether it's at 2044 or
2039 it doesn't really matter because
everyone is always going to be paid
the only way the state of New Hampshire
will end is if the United States as a
country collapses and if that happens
pension assets will not be stock markets
pensions there won't be anything there
so it won't make any difference at all
so this sort of Hardline theoretical
concept that we have to go to
100% doesn't apply that well when you're
talking about a government entity or
State such as such as New Hampshire so I
apologize I went on so long Madam chair
but uh I would I'm still available for
any questions that um anybody might
have thank you may mayor aners are there
any
questions I don't see any hands so thank
you I call Dennis
poran
Madame chair were you calling Mr Corgan
to testify
he has permission to speak he needs to
unmute I apologize I I was hoping you
could hear
me what's that H can you hear me now yes
thank you thank you sorry no he
didn't uh let me uh start
over I'm testifying on behalf of the
Granite State taxpayers and we want to
strongly associate ourselves
with the remarks of Marty and George and
Mr bodry um I was very heartened to hear
that the New Hampshire retirement system
board voted unanimously um to recommend
itl on this bill that's our
recommendation as
well the um
uh my professional opinion as a as a
pension actuary is that there are
important reasons that pension plans
should be fully funded at all times to
provide security to pension plan plan
beneficiaries um and while New
Hampshire's system isn't the worst
funded state plan of the nation it's its
funded ratio of
61% is very poorly funded compared with
private sector
plans no private Pension Plan would be
permitted to operate indefinitely with a
60% funded
ratio the uh pension protection act of
2006 provides that large private sector
pension plans are considered at risk of
defaulting on their liabilities if they
have less than 80% funded ratios using
standard actal assumptions and the New
Hampshire retirement system assumptions
are much weaker than standard actal
assumptions now uh the New Hampshire
system looks bad compared with with
other St State plans as well the tax
Foundation says that in 2019 only 20
states have pension plans that are less
than two-thirds
funded so uh basically all private
sector defined benefit plans pursue 100%
funding by amortising any shortfalls
over seven years and increasing plan
contributions
accordingly we've heard that we the this
is presenting a hardship to uh fund the
unfunded liability now and over the
future 30 years but really the hardship
is caused by the benefits that have been
promised and no one is suggesting that
those benefits be paired back and if
that doesn't happen they simply have to
be paid for they have to be funded the
um we've heard also that this is a a
little relief but a billion and a half
dollar of extra spending by the state of
New
Hampshire even if those are future Bill
uh dollars is is a staggering amount of
money um for the for the state to to
contemplate
so I would I would really urge that uh
an itl
um evaluation recommendation on
this um basically if if this bill passes
the unfunded liability will be instead
of zero at 2039 it'll be 2.3 billion
doll and where's that $2.3 billion doll
going to come
from glad to take any
questions thank you are there any
questions on the
committee I don't see any so thank you
very much thank you anyone else who
wishes to testify on House Bill
390 Madame chair John
Griffin yes Mr Griffin please speak
thank you madam chair and members of the
committee for the record my name is John
L Griffin I'm the CFO for the city of
nashille which a position I've held for
the last 10 years so I've actually
become very familiar with this topic not
to uh say what everybody else said I'll
get into the specifics of nashor and the
kind of the the competing balances that
we're trying to weigh but applying the
increased employer rates that have been
certified by the nhrs for pensionable
payroll wages we're going to see an
increase as May dous indicative of
approximately 4
million every $2 million for the city of
nashor in increased spending or
reductions in revenue is 1% on the tax
rate therefore this particular increase
is 2% % for this P this one item we've
been fortunate uh in the city of
nashille to keep our spending and our
tax increases were under the 3% Mark for
probably nine out of the last 10 years
so this will put a significant burden on
the city uh and as was said previously
Services either Services have to be
reduced or tax burden on a tax pay as
would have to increase the impact of
adopting H Bill HB 390 will have the
effect of reducing the current nhrs
employer rates that have been talked
about and this at this time uh given the
pandemic and the other pressures on city
government as much needed to balance the
competing needs that are facing the
municipalities I do intend toh provide
written testimony encapsulating this
information and I uh am supporting hope
you would support HP 390 and be
available for any questions you may have
than thank you thank you Mr are there
any questions from the
committee seeing none thank you for the
testimony does anyone else wish to speak
on House Bill
390 in that case I will close the public
hearing
let me pull the members how many people
are interested in continuing the exec on
house bille
91 right there are six hands rais
and I see that people raise your
hand i'm trying to raise my hand as well
make
seven just about to vote if we're ready
to vote let's do it sounds like a sounds
like there's enough so resuming the
session on house bu
91 when we left
off
representative shu is online
speak thank you madam chair yes I I was
just going to State um basically the
same thing that uh representative
O'Brien was saying about um comment
about your work affecting uh your
marriage quite often uh having been
married to a law enforcement officer I
know this to be true um in addition to
Firefighters police
officers uh see some pretty nasty things
from time to time and it can't help but
affect your mental
um well-being um and so I think that um
and I I will say I know I've heard
previously that uh divorce rates amongst
uh First Responders are
usually higher than uh the average
population and I think it's because of a
lot of the job stresses that uh it's
difficult you can't even talk about some
of these things when you get home so
it's difficult for a spouse to
understand those kinds of pressures so I
think that um a suicide while it may not
seem to be job related quite often it's
really a result of the stress on the job
thank
you someone else
speak right there's no hands raised and
no one speaking so the motion is ought
to pass by representative Roy and the
clerk representative Roy yes CL yes
representative pearon
absolutely representative
yakovich
yes representative black
yes Representative legro
no representative
Bailey
lar yes
representative is Santo
naso
no representative
goalie yes representative Shu
yes representative Judy is not on video
representative Schmidt
yes representative
Schultz yes representative fellows yes
representative funno yes representative
groden yes representative O'Brien yes
the
chair I'll have to vote
[Music]
no
the
I is
muted repres did you vote Yes or
No I voted
no thank
you right I have four NOS what's the
yeses
no this will not be
[Music]
on I will not write a Minority Report if
any of the other no votes wish to I need
it as as soon as
possible excuse me Madame chair would
you please give us the final vote on
that 14 to4 was my mistake thank
you
you will
write all right thank you all for
surviving a delightful day we will get
through our techn technical
difficulties on Monday we will be
getting through the last of our early
bills and a bunch of other fun stuff and
um hope and I will see you madam chair
very
much Madam chair yes
uh quick question um I just want to be
sure that if members do come in to
attend these hearings that the house
rule be will be adhered to that if
members are in the room they can not
have a mask on if they are seated but if
they're moving around they must put a
mask on I noticed a few times today
people were walking around with no masks
on and I want to make sure that's going
to be adhered
to I believe that that has been the
practice but except for the distressing
incident of the chair falling over but
yes thank you um Can can you please
repeat that it's coming kind of
garbled representative goalie wants to
make sure that we adhere to the best
technique which is we can remove a mask
when we're sitting at our seat or when
are moving around we should wear
one thank you very much for that clar
ification Madam chair and that position
as
well I take we have nothing for
tomorrow no we are through with today's
business
um thank you for today I have another
meeting I'll be leaving Madam chair you
mentioned Monday are you referring to
February 1st Monday February 1 it's
already in the calendar it has been
posted uh I believe we're going to be on
Thursday next week but the days are
being allotted rather oddly so I can't
tell you exactly Mondays in the
calendar I can confirm Madam chairman
that you have um scheduled for a full
day for Thursday uh February
4th Monday and Thursday yes all full
days so we have
fun I don't know what room will be in I
I believe on Monday we're back up on the
third floor but it does when you check
in they tell
us it's in the P if you're here I'm GNA
run some papers up to the fourth floor
for Miriam uh when I get process this
stuff okay actually if you just leave it
right there on the table we'll pick it
up that's the the best way we'll come
down and you know straighten up the room
and get it organized for the next
committee so just leave your your
Clerk's um notes right there and we'll
scan them off to Mariam
Miriam represent
goie yes represent want you to take note
that I did not screw uping the RO at all
this
time duly
noted all right thank you all have a
good weekend read up on Monday's B and
I'll see you then